JOINING US FOR A REGULARLY
SCHEDULED BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
FOR TUESDAY APRIL THIRTEENTH AT
NINE AM BUT FIRST LIKE TO START
OFF BY THANKING ALL IN THE
CHAMBERS PLEASE NOTE THAT WE
ARE MAINTAINING OUR SOCIAL
DISTANCING FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO TESTIFY FEEL
FREE TO CALL IN WE WILL BE
USING A MODERATE TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 ACCESS CODE IS TWO
FOUR. TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
AGAIN THAT'S. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR
TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS WELL
AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO
SO. AND STATE THE AUTHOR OF THE
BILL THAT YOU'RE TESTIFYING IN
THE GIVEN ON THE PRESENTATION.
PLEASE ALSO BE ADVISED IF YOU
ARE A MAIN PROP- PRIMARY
WITNESS PROVIDING TESTIMONY FOR
OR AGAINST A BILL YOUR MAIN
LIVE ON THE LINE. AND YOU WILL
NEED TO MUTE YOURSELF UNTIL YOU
ARE CALLED ON TO SPEAK. WE ALSO
WANT TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION. LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. FOR MEMBERS HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS. TODAY WE HAVE. ON
CONSENT A. B. FOUR EIGHTY FOUR
MEDINA ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN WORD AND ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT FORTY SEVEN CORK
WHICH BE TAKEN UP ON CONSENT
ONCE A QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED.
WE NOTICED THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM BUT PRESENCE OF THE VICE
CHAIR SO WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. MEMBERS THEN WILL GO
INTO A FILE ITEM FILE ORDER
WHICH IS FILE. I DON'T NUMBER
ONE WHICH IS AB FOUR SIXTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN FRIEDMAN.
I SOMEONE FRIEDMAN THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
BOTH I THINK I'LL FEEL FREE 2%
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND MISTER
CHAIR I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR ALL YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL- AB FOUR
SIXTY IT WOULD PREVENT THE SALE
OF EMOTIONAL SUPPORT ANIMALS
AND THEIR EQUIPMENT AS HAVING
THE RIGHT OF A GUIDE TO SIGNAL
OR SERVICE DOG. AND ALSO
REQUIRES THE SALE OF EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMALS AND EQUIPMENT
TO BE ACCOMPANIED BY DISCLOSURE
SO THAT THE PUBLIC CAN
CONSUMERS UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAVING THESE ANIMALS ACTUALLY
MEANS IN THE EYES OF THE LAW.
THE BILL WOULD ALSO PROHIBIT A
HEALTH CARE PRACTITIONER
PROVIDING DOCUMENTATION
RELATING TO AN INDIVIDUAL'S
NEED FOR AN EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
DOG THAT IS NOT A GUIDE SIGNAL
OR SERVICE DOG TO FINE AND LET
THE HEALTHCARE PRACTITIONER
COMPLIES WITH CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS MEMBERS THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN AN EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMAL AND A SERVICE
DOG AND THE TWO CLASSIFICATIONS
DO NOT. ALLOW THE OWNER OF THAT
ANIMAL TO HAVE THE SAME LEVEL
OF PUBLIC ACCESS IS DEFINED BY
THE LAW THIS IS NOT WELL
UNDERSTOOD BY THE PUBLIC AND
BECAUSE OF THAT THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITY ACT BUT THEIR OWN
PRIVILEGE ACCESS AND PUBLIC
SPACES. THAT CAN PUT OTHER
PEOPLE AROUND THEM IN HARM'S
WAY AND THERE ARE MANY REALLY
SAD EXAMPLES OF THIS HAPPENING.
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WHO
USED. TRAINED SERVICE DOGS
EARNED THEIR RIGHT TO BE IN
PUBLIC SPACES AS A RESULT OF A
RIGOROUS TRAINING PROCESS. THAT
ENSURES THAT THERE SERVICE DOGS
SATISFIED BEHAVIORAL STANDARDS
UNDER THE ADA TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY THEMSELVES BUT ALSO THE
PUBLIC IS SAFE. FROM WHAT CAN
BE DISRUPTIVE ANIMALS. THE
FRAUDULENT SELLING OF EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT DOGS IN IDENTIFYING
EQUIPMENT IS ENTITLING THE SAME
ACCESS RIGHTS OF SERVICE DOG.
NOT ONLY CREATES CONFUSION FOR
THE OWNER OF THE ANIMAL BUT
ALSO THE GENERAL PUBLIC AS THEY
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH EIGHTY
LAWS. ADDITIONALLY THE
PERCEIVED NEED FOR THIS
IDENTIFYING EQUIPMENT TO THE
BUSINESSES STRESSING THIS
REQUIREMENT. IS DEFRAUDING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. THE
INSPIRATION FOR THIS BILL TO ME
CAME FROM HEARING A NEWS
REPORT. ABOUT A FAMILY THAT HAD
BOUGHT. I SUPPOSE AN EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMAL FOR THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS FOR THE ARTISTIC SON
ONLY TO HAVE THAT SAME ANIMAL
TURN AROUND AND KILL OTHER
ANIMALS IN THEIR HOUSE. WELL IT
TURNED OUT THAT THIS DOG HAD
JUST BEEN PURCHASED HAVE BEEN
ADOPTED FROM THE POUND A FEW
DAYS EARLIER. NOT GIVEN ANY
TRAINING AND SOLD TO THESE
PEOPLE FOR THIS VERY FRAGILE
AND VULNERABLE CHILD. THAT'S A
TRAGEDY THAT IS FRAUD THAT HAS
REALLY SAD CONSEQUENCES FOR
EVERYBODY AND WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC AND- THE ANIMALS. AB
FOUR SIXTY WILL HELP CURTAIL
THE MISREPRESENTATION OF BUYING
AND SELLING EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
DOGS. AND THEY'RE IDENTIFYING
EQUIPMENT IS HAVING EQUAL
ACCESS RIGHTS AS TRAINED
SERVICE DOGS. CREATING A SAFER
PUBLIC SPACE FOR EVERYONE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT THIS
MORNING AS WELL AS CROSSMAN
FROM CANINE COMPANIONS AND
ROBERT DOW FROM GUIDE DOGS FOR
THE BLIND. I APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THE COULD PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES TO SPEAK THERE ARE
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES. AND WILL
ALLOW FOR UP TO TWO MINUTES PER
PRIMARY WITNESS PLEASE. FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHATEVER YOU'RE
READY. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
WALLACE BRUNCH- I AND TO
COMMUNICATE AND ADVOCACY AT.
GROUP CAN I CAN. MY SECOND
COMPETE SERVICE DOG THE VICTIM
OF DOCTOR MAULED TIMES ORDER TO
A HALF YEAR PARKER. SHE WAS AN
EXCEPTIONAL DOG BUT I TEN
INCIDENTS. WITH DOGS PLACES BUT
HAVE TALKED ABOUT SUPPORT
ANIMALS NOT UNDER LAW. SHE
COULD NO LONGER WORK EVENING
THE HOME BECAUSE MY RETIRED
SERVICE WITH CALL HIM SHE- I
RETIRE SERVICE DOG MARC H. AND
LOST MY THE. IMPACT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO TRULY RELY ON
SERVICE DOGS TO LEAD
INDEPENDENT LIVES I ASKED YOU
TO JOIN ME IN AND- THE BILL.
AND PRODUCE BLACK. OF THE
COUNTRY. CHECK. PUBLIC PLACE.
EITHER AND SERVICE OR PEOPLE
WHO ARE TO NESTLE WITH THAT.
REALLY DANGEROUS LACK OF THE
THAT IS BEING PROVIDED BY THE
BUSINESS THEMSELVES THANK YOU.
AND IT. IS OPEN. THANK YOU MOM
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO- TO HAVE TODAY-
JUST A COUPLE. FROM EVERY
SURVEY 79% OF SERVICE DOG USERS
REPORT. BASICALLY GETTING INTO
INSULATION JUST ENOUGH YOU THE
DOCTOR OR LOOKING BY A DOG IN
PERSPECTIVE PUBLIC SPACE. TWO
THIRTY OF SERVE DAHLE USERS.
ARE INTIMIDATED ENOUGH AFFECT
ENOUGH THAT THEY TO THE QUALITY
OF LIFE AND BEEN A FOR BY ACTED
BY INCOME INCREASED MEDIA RAPID
UP OF AWFUL AWFUL PIECE FIX
RICKETS WITH DR FROM. PERSON ON
MANY. MANY LAW. MY GUIDE DOG
SITS UNDER THE SEA AND OF ME ON
THE PLAY WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE
ANY MY GUIDE DOG. THANK ME
AROUND IF. DAY CONSTRUCTION
SITE ON THIS I THINK YOU NEED
TO WALK. MY GUIDE DOG CORRECT
ME ACROSS STREET. THE SUPPORT
IT ALSO BLAH ME FROM THE
POOREST IF I CAN. THE COSTING
ON THE SOUTH SIXTY TO SELL.
THIS TRAINING IS NOT A- BY S.
GRAHAM IF HE FOR TWENTY DOLLARS
FIFTY DOLLARS A HUNDRED DOLLARS
TO OBTAIN BE SIGNIFICANT OF
MEANINGLESS. THIS IS A
DANGEROUS SITUATION FOR ALL
INVOLVED. I JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND MY
COLLEAGUE. EIGHT ASKING YOU TO
SUPPORT. FOUR SIX EIGHT TO
PROTECT THE SAFETY OF THE
PUBLIC TO PROTECT THE WELFARE
OF THE STOCKS BOTH BACK IN.
COMPROMISED DATA SAID YOU AND
SERVICE ANIMAL LIKE DOGS HAVE
THANK TO PROTECT RIGHT AND
SHOULD ANIMAL AND- TWO ONE
SAFELY IN ON. THE CARD FIFTY
OKAY. WITH DIGNITY THANK YOU
FOR THE AND WE AT MANY. THANK
YOU MUCH FOR TEST THAT CAN THE
OPPORTUNE FOR PER WIN. TO
PROVIDE TEN. ONE L. OKAY UP THE-
TOPIC THAT MOMENT IN TIME BEEN
OF THE PUBLIC TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS ISSUE ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE
IN THE CHAMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR SIXTY EIGHT. SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR SIXTY EIGHT. YOU KNOW
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT MODERATOR
WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. WISHING TO SPEAK. IN
SUPPORT JUST SIMPLY BY
SIGNIFYING THEIR SUPPORT AS
WELL AS THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF THEY WISH TO DO
SO. FOR ASSEMBLY BILL. FOUR
SIXTY EIGHT. AND FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IF YOU ARE IN FAVOR
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME.
AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE TWENTY SIX. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS IS DIFFICULT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS CHRIS WYSOCKI
WITH WESTERN MANUFACTURED
HOUSING COMMUNITIES ASSOCIATION
WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER. PUBLIC COMMENTS IN
FAVOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR THE NOW MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OPERATOR ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SIXTY
EIGHT. AND ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND
I SEE NO PUBLIC LINES IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC NOW HERE
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ON THIS BILL. SENIOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE COMMITTEE CHAMBERS
WITHIN TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ON ASSEMBLY BILL. FOUR SIXTY
EIGHT SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHICH IF HE SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION NOW ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME. OKAY NO CLOCK. OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME. I SAW WOMAN FRIEDMAN
WHICH TOOK. I DO APPRECIATE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS THING YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
WHEN FREE WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PASSION FOR THIS TO SURE THAT
STAMP THE- PRACTICES WILL HELP
SUPPORT THE LEGAL. OF THE
LEDGER. TYPE OF SERVICES THAT
WE NEED IN THIS MOMENT IN TIME-
THIS DOESN'T GO TO PASS A BOTH
SIDES AND GET TO THAT ONCE A
FORM IS A STEP. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY FRIEDMAN. CALLING
THEM NOW BEEN MOVED. A OR. IF
WE CAN THAT COMING THE SERGEANT
I DON'T SEE ANY ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS. AT THIS TIME SO WE'LL
GO GO DANCING MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU- TO FILE
ITEM NO ELEVEN THEN AS AS WE
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WILL GO TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF IT'S OKAY
WHICH IS A FILE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
SAFEGUARD OPIOID MEDICATIONS
AND REDUCE THE ACT OF PILFERING
A POWERFUL ON RAMP TO THE
NATION'S CURRENT OPIOID
ADDICTION CRISIS. THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE A PHARMACIST TO
PROVIDE SCHEDULED TO HAND TO
AND PRESCRIPTION DRUGS I E.
MORPHINE OXYCODONE FOR RENTAL
AND IN A LOCKABLE CONTAINER.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS BILL AND ACCEPT
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. I ALSO LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS ABOUT OF
PRESCRIBERS ABILITY TO OPT OUT
ON BEHALF OF THEIR PATIENTS IN
CERTAIN CASES. PILFERING THE
ACT OF SNEAKING A SMALL NUMBER
OF PILLS HOPING THAT IT WILL GO
UNDETECTED IS THE LEADING
SOURCE OF USED OPIOID ABUSE.
STUDIES SHOW THAT EACH YEAR
NEARLY SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN FROM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY BETWEEN THE AGES OF
TWELVE AND SEVENTEEN. INITIATE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE BY
PILFERING MEDICATION FROM AND
AN ADULT IN THEIR HOME. THE OUT
DATED CHILD RESISTANT
PRESCRIPTION VIALS CURRENTLY IN
USE HAVE NOT BEEN MODIFIED IN
NEARLY FIFTY YEARS. IN THE
FEDERAL POISON PREVENTION
PACKAGING ACT WAS ENACTED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY THE GOAL WAS
TO PREVENT CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF FIVE FROM GAINING ACCESS
TO ASPIRIN. TODAY THOSE SAME
CHILD LOCKS ARE USED TO PROTECT
MEDICATIONS RANGING FROM COUGH
MEDICINE TO PRESCRIPTION PAIN
MANAGEMENT MEDICATIONS THAT ARE
EIGHTY TIMES STRONGER THAN
MORPHINE. LEADING PUBLIC HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE CALLED FOR
IMPROVED PACKAGING OF OPIOIDS
AND OTHER ADDICTIVE MEDICATIONS
FOR SEVERAL YEARS. REQUIRING
LOCKING PRESCRIPTION VIALS FOR
POWERFUL NARCOTICS IS A LOW
COST WAY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
MODERNIZE THE ANTIQUATED
FEDERAL LAWS THAT ARE PARTIALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR CAUSING THIS
NATIONWIDE EPIDEMIC. WITH ME
TODAY ARE MARK BURKE AT WITH
AND BE ADVOCACY AND SHERRY
DAILY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION
PROGRAMS AND PROFESSIONALS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR. WHEN
I'M OF MOVE ONTO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE HAVE- A
MISSED FOR GOD PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT WHEN YOU'RE READY IN
THE MID TO TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RANDY LOOK FOR CARRYING THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION- AS WAS
MENTIONED BEFORE. ACCORDING TO
RECENT STUDIES- ADOLESCENCE ONE
ADOLESCENT BEGINS ABUSE
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION EVERY
MINUTE. TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS A
YEAR. THAT IS THE SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND THE DOCTOR REGULATE
MENTIONS AT FOURTEEN THIRTY
COMPARATIVELY ELIMINATE HELP
FOR HIM- BY DOING THREE THINGS
NUMBER ONE IT ALERTS THE
PATIENT. OF THE SERIOUS NATURE
OF THIS MEDICATION. NUMBER. TWO
AT THE- DISINCENTIVE TO
MEDICATION- STOPS FROM HAVE BIG
THE- BILE CANNOT BE OPEN. AND
NUMBER THREE A QUICKLY ALERTS
THAT MEDICATION HAS BEEN WITH.
AND THIS IS A CRITICAL BECAUSE
IF BE PAGE- WHETHER THAT PARA-
WORLDSPAN WERE SOMEONE ELSE IN
THE HOUSE NO THAT THEIR MEDIC
BEEN TAMPERED WITH. THEY CAN
MEET. TAKE REMEDIATION. AND WE
KNOW WITH TREATMENT- THE SOONER
YOU BEGIN TO THE SOONER YOU
FINE OUT THERE'S ISSUE THE
BETTER CHANCE THERE IS LONG. TO
SIX- EVERY STEP. HAS RE SHOWN
THE- DRUG USE HAS A SHARPLY
DURING LAST YEAR THE PANDA. SO
THESE NUMBERS OF SIX BALLOT. AT
ELEVEN EVERY. MOST LIKELY WILL
FLY IN THE NECK THAT TO
EIGHTEEN AT THE- SIX- LOCKABLE
VIALS OR SO FOR NAPS NEXT IN
THE BILL BY STAYING. THE
HAVEN'T BEEN UPDATED FOR YEARS.
CURRENTLY THE STILL BY WHOLE
FOR LACK THAN A DOLLAR AND BY
CAN. THE CAR OF A ONE MONTH
SUPPLY OF A TYPICAL. DRUG RANGE
ANYWHERE FROM HUNDRED AND
EIGHT. TO SIX HOW DOLLARS SO
AGAIN A VERY SMALL PRICE TO PAY
TO ELIMINATE BILL FOR.
ADDITIONALLY THIS PERFORMED IS
TO BE A REAL. FOR THAT IN THERE
TO. IS IN PLAY AND IS OPERABLE.
AND USE FOR OTHER ISSUES. WITH
IT IN FOR AND WE THE AMEND THAT-
DOCTOR RANDY HAS A- WE WOULD
REALLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY. OPERATOR AND
THEIR ANY MEMBERS OF THE ON THE
LINES WHICH TO SPEAK INTO AT
THIS. ANYONE CAN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IN YOU ARE IN FAVOR
PLEASE PRAY ONE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR MAY WE HAD A SECOND
PRIMARY WITNESS- SHERRY DAVE
YES THEY DID THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DOCTOR AND LET IT.
OPERATORS ARE ADDITIONAL
PRIMARY THAT WE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE MINUTES FEELS
WHENEVER YOU'RE A. OKAY. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TWENTY
DELGADO IN THE AFRICAN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. AND NEXT UP TO ONE
FORTY NINE. IN LINE FORTY NINE
THAT SHERRY DALY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THANK YOU SORRY TO
THE TECHNICAL GLITCH THERE THIS
MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON
HONORABLE CHAIR MEMBERS SHERRY
DALY WITH THE K. COULD OF THE
FROM THAT COULD. BUT OVER
TWENTY ADDICTS COUNSELOR AND
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED TREATMENT
PROGRAM THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
RECOVERY RESIDENTS THE AND
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN WORK
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I'M TODAY
TO VOTE SUPPORT FOR A BI
FOURTEEN THIRTY. AT THE ACTORS
THE DISORDER TREATMENT THE AND
PERSONALLY AFTER PARENT FROM A
STAFF WALKING TOLD ARE ANY AND
VERY EFFECTIVE PREVENTION
MEASURE CONCERNING YOUNG ADULTS
AND I. AGE GROUP THIS MATURE
ENOUGH TO KEEP RISK THROUGH
POPULAR FOR THAT. STEALING OR
THREE PILLS FROM THE CAN OVER
OF TIME APART LIKELY BE TO TAKE.
AN ENTIRE OF MEDIC SUDDENLY
GOING MISSING. MARC BERMAN WITH.
THE TRAGEDY THAT CAN OCCUR WHEN
THE POWERFUL MEDICATIONS ARE
SURE CATHOLIC PARDON THE MIXED
WITH ALCOHOL THANK YOU SAVAGE
HAD TWO AMAZING SONS NICK AND
JACK WHO LOVE TALKING TALK
ABOUT ONE LATE NIGHT HANG OUT.
WHEN IT CAME HOME FROM COLLEGE
TO CELEBRATE YOUNGER BROTHER
JACK HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION THE
TO ATTEND A SMALL PARTY WITH
FRIENDS. WE'RE OPIOID ALCOHOL
SHARE. AND I'M WHEN THEY WENT
PICK UP LAUNDRY AND ROOM AS
WELL ONE KID COME HOME COLLEGE.
SHE GOT HIM UNRESPONSIVE.
UNRESPONSIVE I BELIEVE THE-
WHAT WAS. CPR PARAMEDICS
ARRIVED BUT WENT TOWARDS THE
BASEMENT WHERE ANOTHER CULPRIT
THAT HAD BEEN RECEIVED. THAT
MIKE BECKY LAW TO OCCUR FOUR
SONS TO OPIOID OVERDOSE. FROM A
PERSONAL PERSPECTIVE I HAVE
EXPERIENCE COVERING IN MY OWN
HOME. ALTHOUGH I WAS VERY
DIFFERENT THE TRAGICALLY DAMAGE
THE LIVES WITH TODAY AS AN
ADVOCATE IN THE FIELD OF
ADDICTION TREATMENT FOR THREE
DECADES I BELIEVE MY CHILDREN
HAD SOMEHOW BECOME IMMUNE TO
SUCH JUSTICE ORDER. AFTER ALL I
DID ALL THE RIGHT THINGS I
HAVEN'T TALKED I GAVE
ALTERNATIVE. AND EXCLUSIVE AN
APARTMENT RIGHT PROJECT NO THAT
WOULD BE AVAILABLE LEVERAGED A
STUDENT MUSICIANS DANCERS
ATHLETES. NONE OF MY CHILDREN
WOULD BE AFFECTED BY THE.
DISEASE OF ADDICTION. WHEN MY
YOUNG CHILD RETURN UNITS IN
YOUR WHICH SIGNIFICANT. SARDAR
I WAS. IN COULD. HOW STARTED
WHO INFLUENCED HER WHY WOULD
SHE EVER START TAKING DRUGS I
ASK. WHO'S NOT UNTIL EIGHTEEN
MONTHS INTO RECOVERY THAT I ASK
SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS. WHEN
SHE TOLD ME SHE BEGAN USING AND
MY HOME. BE A LEFTOVER NORCO
FROM SURGERY I HAVE I WAS
SHOCKED AND IN DISBELIEF. MY
HEART THANK THAT I THOUGHT IF I
ONLY KNEW. HOW MUCH PAIN AND
SUFFERING COULD I'VE STATED HER
LIFE AND MY OWN FAMILY. HOW
MUCH TIME DO WE LOSE AND HOW
MUCH MONEY WOULD BLOCK PAYING
PER MONTH THE PRESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT ALL BECAUSE WE DID
NOT HAVE AN EARLY WARNING
SYSTEM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REGULATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
URGE YOUR AYE ABOUT THANK YOU.
FOR IN THE IN THE NEXT CALLER
IN SUPPORT PLEASE. WE HAVE A NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY.
SENIOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
HEARING THE CHAMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
MA'AM ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. IN A COMMITTEE HEARING
ROOMS. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. SAYING NO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM.
WILL NOW GO TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. WELL THEN OPEN UP
THE LINES OPERATOR. TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. A WE
HAVE UP TO TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TWO
MINUTES EACH PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT WHATEVER YOU'RE
READY. WE WILL NOT A MORNING
FORTY. FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AFTER
TEARING COMMITTEE MEMBERS
NINETEEN RECORD THE CALL ARE
GOING TO REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE NATIONAL
FIFTY THIRTEEN DRUGSTORE AND WE
ARE CLOSED AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
WE ARE STRONGLY COMMITTED TO
COULD BE APPEALING IN ANOTHER
PRESCRIPTION DRUG ABUSE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHILE WE
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE THE
OPTICAL AND MITIGATE BACK IN
THE FEES THAT THE FACT. THAT WE
DON'T THINK AB PARKING THIRTY
OF THE APPROPRIATE SOLUTION FOR
NUMBER OR EVEN THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVAL ON TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THAT REQUIRED IN THE PHARMACY
AT THE OPERA WALKABLE STORAGE
PRODUCTS ARE CONTROLLED BY
THREE DAYS WHICH CAN. INCLUDE
LOCKABLE PRESCRIPTION VIAL. IF
I THIRD PARTY. DISPLAYED
APARTMENT EVEN IF YOU
ACCEPTABLE PATIENTS WHO RECEIVE
BACK. MAKING IT THE PARKING THE
NEXT. AB FOURTEEN THIRTY CAUSES
SERIOUS PATIENTLY COOPER.
FOUNDATION MAY FIND IT. TO OPEN
IN MAY WALKABLE VIAL OR YOU CAN
MAKE FORGET THAT. TO BE ENABLED
I WITHIN THE- PATIENTS NEED TO
RETURN THEIR CAP MAIN BE ABLE
TO RE. AFTER HOURS OR PRINT
RADIO BETTER EITHER. WE BELIEVE
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SAID
THEREFORE NEED TO BE MADE
VOLUNTARY WHICH WOULD ADDRESS
THESE THINGS BECAUSE- THAT
PERFECTLY BUT THE DECISION IN
THE FUTURE I CAN'T. AT FOURTEEN
THIRTY OFFICE PREDICT CREATED
MEDICAID WORK WORK WORK
CALENDAR FOR PHARMACIES THAT'S
WHAT THE MAINTAINED A
COMBINATION COLLECTIBLE BY.
ADDING THE CAPABILITY TO
PHARMACY RECORDS IT'S GOING TO
BE PROBLEMATIC TO IMPLEMENT
MAINTAIN. AND WE DON'T
CURRENTLY HAVE THE SYSTEMS. IN
PLACE TO KEEP TRACK OF THE FACT
THAT. I BERMAN BE LOCKED UP FOR
BILL BECAUSE THE BLOCK VIAL.
THREE PARTY I MEAN IF.
IMPLEMENT THE COMMUNITY PROCESS
AND CON. CALL UP WITH MANY.
COMPLETELY FINANCIAL BURDEN ON.
AND DISTRACTORS. CARE WE HAVE
OPPORTUNITY. EVERY AND THEN
THAT WOULD OP. MAINLY MAKING A
LOCKABLE GOING- MOVING THE-
THEM IN. TO FOR. WE APPRECIATE
THE AND MINISTER I DIDN'T
COMMITTEE AND I. THAT
ESPECIALLY RELATING FARMING BY
A BILL. BUT WE ARE CLOSE EIGHTY
FOURTEEN. WE ARE HOWEVER
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THEY CAN TO MAKE THE
BILL WORKABLE. MEMBER I'M SURE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT NEXT AND PRIMARY A WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE FORTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING SECOND QUARTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
WANTED TO ECHO THE APPRECIATION
OF THE AUTHORS FOCUSED ON THIS
ISSUE HOWEVER THE GENERAL
ASSOCIATION IS EXPRESSING IN A
POST POSITION AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY THANK YOU. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT THAT'S ON
BEHALF EMERICA BECAUSE IT WILL
BE T. Y. H. DISTRICT NINE AND
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WE ACTUALLY HAD AN
OPPOSE UNLESS. AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL BUT LIKE I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENT TO PROVIDE FOR
PATIENTS OPT OUT WE APPRECIATE
COMMITMENT DEVELOP LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ALLOW PRESCRIBER OCT
UNDER CERTAIN. CIRCUMSTANCES
SUCH AS WHEN THE PATIENT IS A
MINOR WE AFFORD TO WORK WITH
THEM. THANK YOU. IT WILL MOVE
TO LINE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING BRITAIN
YOUNG FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HERE IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE A NO FURTHER LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING THE CHAMBERS WE CAN%
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. C. NINE
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOMS. SCENE NO
MEMBERS OF PUBLIC WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME DR REMEDY WAS TO
CLOSE. WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST TONIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE ARE CURRENTLY STILL
ARE LACKING A CORPSMAN WE'LL
GET TO THAT ITEM WHAT'S WE ARE
STEPS QUORUM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DOCTOR ROOMS OKAY. HOW TO
MOVE BACK INTO FOLLOW ORDER.
FILE ITEM NUMBER. TWO GET THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWO NINETY THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. SIMMER
COVERED THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES
PLEASE FEEL FREE PERCENT
WHATEVER IT. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS. AB TWO NINETY
THREE IS A REDUCTION OF OUR
FORMER. AB TWO THREE THREE TWO
WHICH ARE BOTH ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND NO NO
VOTES. THIS BILL ALSO REFLECTS
BROKE DOWN WITH THE CEMETERY
AND MORTUARY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR. FOR NOW
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL AND I WANT
TO THANK THEM FOR WORKING WITH
US TO GET TO THAT POINT AS WELL
AS THE WORK OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. A TO HELP US- TO ALL GET
THEIR- AB TWO NIGHTS WE WOULD
ADDRESS. ISSUES REGARDING- THE
DISEASE AS STATE OR ACTUALLY
JUST APOLOGIZE IF TRYING TO
PROVIDE LONG NEW CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS. FRANKLIN PRE NEED
FUNERAL ARRANGEMENTS HELD IN
TRUST BY FUNERALS TALISMAN.
USUALLY THE DECEASED'S ESTATE
WILL CONTACT BETWEEN ALMOST
OPTIONS WILL FILL THE DISEASE.
AGREEMENT FOR FUNERAL SERVICES
HOWEVER IN CASES WHERE THE
STATE IS NOT AWARE OF THE
TRUST. AND IS NOT TO FILL THE
SERVICES PROMISED AND PAID FOR.
THE TRUST ACCOUNT CAN LIKE DOOR
DORMANT INDEFINITELY DESPITE
THE DEATH OF PRESUMED DEATH THE
BENEFICIARY. AS A FORM OF
INTANGIBLE PROPERTY THESE
ACCOUNTS FALL UNDER OUR STATE'S
UNCLAIMED PROPERTY LAW. BUT
THESE BUSINESSES ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO HAVE CONSISTENT
CONTACT WITH THE OWNER OF THE
RECORD. OWNER OF RECORD NOR
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS FAMILY LIVED
IN A TRUST ACCOUNTS. WHAT AB
TWO NINETY THREE WHAT IS. A
HOLLOW TO DRESSES. WE WOULD DO
IT WOULD DECLARE THE PARTY
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPORTING. OF
ABANDONED SUCH ACCOUNTS.
ESTABLISH DORMANCY TRIGGERS TO
RESUME THE DEATH THE
BENEFICIARY AND REQUIRE A
CONTACT PROTOCOL WITH THE
OWNERS OF THE UNCLEAN PRE NEED.
FUNERAL TRUST ACCOUNT BY JUST
THIS LONG STANDING ISSUE. AB
TWO NINETY THREE WILL PROTECT
CONSUMERS AND THEIR SURVIVING
LOVED ONES PROVIDING
CONVENIENTLY LOCATED CLAIM USE
PREMIUM FEDERAL FUNDS. BUT DID
PROVIDE SPORTING TESTIMONY'S
BEEN TRIPLE FROM THE STATE
COMPTROLLER BUT HE'S. OFFICE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS A SIMILAR. WHEN
OPEN OF THE LAW FOR WOULD INTO.
OF TWO MINUTES PLEASE FREE TO
PAY WHENEVER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS- THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY KEPT BY.
VENTURA WITH THE OFFICE OF THE
COMPTROLLER BETTY I ALSO ENJOY
A NIGHT MORE UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
DIVISION ON THE LINE WITH US
FOR ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
CONTROL USE PLEASED TO SPONSOR
AB TWO NINETY THREE MY FAMILY
MEMBER KALRA WHICH IS IMPORTANT
BILL TO ENSURE CONSUMERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES CAN LOCATE CLAIM.
I MEAN WE NEED TO GET HELP
TRUST ACCOUNT. AB TWO THREE AND-
BEEN KINGDOM PROPERTY LAW AND-
WHEN AND WHAT CAN. WE NEED YOU
KNOW TRUCKING BECOME PEOPLE
DISTRICT. TO UNDER LAW- PROVIDE.
TO BILL CLINTON AND PENAL STATE.
RETURNING FUND HELP IN A BAND
CAL THEN. ARE THERE HEIRS
PROVIDING ESTABLISHMENT CLEAR
DIRECTION FOR WHEN THE REPORT.
MANY FUNDS THAT NEED TO BE AND
ACCOUNT. MANY THE LIABILITY OF
HOLDING UNCLAIMED PROPERTY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPTIONS
OUTSIDE AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IN ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC ON THE PHONE.
LINES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. THE END
OF THEIR IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JERRY MEMBERS JERRY
KATZMAN UP OUT OF THE CEMETERY
AND MORTUARY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA A FORMALLY IN THE
NEUTRAL FOR THE PROVISION- AND
WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS BY
THE DOCTOR SEVEN MEMBER KALRA
THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE
AND THE COMMITTEE TO DEVELOP A
BILL THAT INCORPORATE INPUT
FROM OUR INDUSTRY ON A NUMBER
OF ISSUES TO MAKE SURE THIS
WILL BE WORKABLE BUT IT'S AN
ACTED INTO LAW. THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE BUT NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT SOME FAVORITE THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND A
DIFFERENT MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS ON THE
COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
SEEING NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION.
WITH ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
CURRENTLY ON THE PHONE LINES AT
THIS MOMENT. AND IF THEY'RE IN
A POSITION AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND I'M
SHOWING NO PUBLIC COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS OR IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. SEE NONE. THE
MOVE ON THE TRACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME. C. NONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA JEWISH TO CLOSE.
STUDY US FOR EITHER THE PUPPY
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE
STILL ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE
SO A TAKE ON THE ITEM ONE TWO
THOUSAND QUORUM. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SOME OF KALRA THEN YOU'RE
A SECOND ITEM. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE EIGHTY FOUR THIS ALSO
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THE BOTH SIDES.
WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SUBMIT MATURE MISTER CHAIRMAN
BURS PRODUCTION PERCENT EIGHTY
THREE EIGHTY FOUR. WANT TO
CONFIRM THAT ALL THE ACCEPTED
COMMITTEES TECHNOL MENACE IT
ALIGNS. WITH THE REST OF THE
BILL'S LANGUAGE I WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
AND GUIDANCE ON THIS BILL.
THREE YEARS AGO THIS COMMITTEE
PASSED AB TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN.
WHICH LLOWED VETERINARIANS
DISCUSSED THE USE OF CANNABIS
WITHOUT FEAR OF LOSING THEIR
STATE LICENSE AND ENABLE
CANNABIS FOR THERAPEUTIC ANIMAL
USED TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO
CONSUMERS. IN REGULATED
DISPENSARIES. THE DISCUSSION
PIECE OF AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
ONE ON THE PASSED BOTH HOUSES
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. AND
WAS SIGNED INTO LAW BY GOVERNOR
BROWN SINCE THEN THERE'S BEEN
EVER INCREASING EVIDENCE
SUPPORTING THE ROLE FOR
CANNABIS USE WITH THERAPEUTIC
BENEFITS AND MANY PET OWNERS.
ARE ALREADY ENGAGING WITHOUT A
CLEAR RECOMMENDATION AND
GUIDANCE FROM THE VETERINARIAN.
IT IS TIME TO ALLOW
VETERINARIANS TO BE ABLE TO
RECOMMEND THE USE OF CANNABIS
ON AN ANIMAL PATIENTS FOR
THERAPEUTIC PURPOSES. ENABLE
THESE PRODUCTS TO COME TO
MARKET THAT ARE SAFE AND
CLEARLY LABELED FOR PET USE
RATHER THAN PET OWNERS USING
CANNABIS PRODUCTS. DESIGNED FOR
HUMAN USE ON THEIR PETS OR
REVERTING TO UNDERGROUND
MARKET. EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
FOUR WOULD REQUIRE THE
VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD TO
ADOPT GUIDELINES FOR
VETERINARIANS TO FOLLOW IN
RECOMMENDING THE USE OF
CANNABIS DERIVED. THERAPEUTIC
PRODUCTS ON AN ANIMAL WITHIN
THE VETERINARIAN CLIENT PATIENT
RELATIONSHIP. SIMILAR
GUIDELINES FOR PHYSICIANS
RECOMMENDING CANNABIS WERE
DEVELOPED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA. TO ENSURE
CANNABIS PRODUCTS INTENDED FOR
USE ON AN ANIMAL CAN BE
AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS IN A
REGULATED MARKET. AB THREE
EIGHTY FOUR ADDS THESE PRODUCTS
THE DEFINITION- UNDER THE
MINUTE MEDICINE ON. ADULT USE
CANNABIS REGULATION AND SAFETY
YEAH. AND ALLOW THESE PRODUCTS
TO BE. TO LICENSE. IF A DEER TO
CANADA REGULATE ABOUT MANY
THOUGHT **** LABELING.
CONSUMERS CALIFORNIA WIDE
ACCESS CANNABIS AND MANY PET
OWNERS. ALREADY LOOKING AT KIND
OF A PROVIDER PARTICULARLY
THEIR PET. LET'S MAKE SURE
WE'RE PROVIDING PET OWNERS WITH
THE TOOLS TO BETTER INFORM
THEIR DECISION. ON HOW BEST TO
USE CANNABIS PRODUCTS FOR THEIR
PETS PROMOTE SAFE. RESPONSIBLE
USE. I BELIEVE THIS BILL
STRIKES A REASONABLE BALANCE.
BETWEEN THE EXISTING
COMPREHENSIVE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK FOR CANNABIS. AND THE
ABILITY OF VETERINARY
PROFESSIONALS PROVIDE CLEAR
RECOMMENDATIONS GUIDANCE. FOR
THEIR CLIENTS. AB THREE EIGHTY
FOUR SUPPORTED BY CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
AND THE VETERINARY KIND OF THE
NOIDA CAN I MEAN I CAN'T I
MEAN. AS WELL AS BUSINESS
GROUPS LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
AND BEST FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY
ONE OF THE NATION'S LEADING
ANIMAL WELFARE. AND RESCUE
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS. WITH
WITH US TODAY ON THE PHONE. IS
A DOCTOR TIM XU FOUNDER AND CEO
OF THAT. CD AND THE FOUNDER OF
ANIMAL CANNABIS COALITION AS
WELL AS ELIZABETH ORECK.
NATIONAL MANAGER OF INITIATIVES
FOR BEST FRIENDS ANIMAL SOCIETY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
OFFERED WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR THE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES EACH.
AND WILL BEGIN WITH DOCTOR SHE-
GET MORE CHAIRMAN. AND MEMBERS
OF THE CA. MY NAME IS DR JAMES.
ANIMALS THAT MERION PRACTICE
GENERAL MOTORS. OKAY MEDICINE.
BARBARA THIRTY BENEFITS OF
CANNABIS HUMANS AND PRACTICE
INTO FIFTEEN JUST BUT V. D. SO
THAT I CAN PROVIDE ANIMALS THE
BENEFITS. AS A HEALTHCARE
PRACTITIONER I HAVE A MORAL AND
ETHICAL OBLIGATION TO PURSUE IN
UNDERSTAND ALL THERAPEUTIC
AVENUES THAT PATIENTS CAN
BENEFIT FROM. ANIMALS SUFFER
FROM DISEASES JUST LIKE PEOPLE
THEY STRUGGLE WITH PAIN ANXIETY
INFLAMMATION NAUSEA SEIZURES
AND END OF LIFE CHALLENGES. ALL
THESE ARE CONDITIONS THAT WE
KNOW CANNABIS CAN HELP WITH.
OVER THE PAST SIX YEARS WE'VE
SEEN COUNTLESS PET TO BE
PROVIDED REMARKABLE BENEFITS
FROM CANNABIS. IN SOME CASES BE
BENEFITS HAVE BEEN LIFESAVING.
SUCH AS WITH PETS SUFFERING
FROM EPILEPSY AND HAVING DAILY
SEIZURES OR ARTHRITIC PETS
HAVING DIFFICULTY GETTING
AROUND WITH PAINFUL JOINTS.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN BECAUSE PET
OWNERS TELETECH CANNABIS
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF THEIR PETS.
BUT ARE THE SOURCE OF MEDICAL
INFORMATION FOR PET OWNERS YEAH
THEY'VE BEN PREVENTED FROM
PROVIDING VALUABLE INFORMATION
PET OWNERS NEED TO MAKE BETTER
DECISIONS FOR THEIR PETS HEALTH
CARE. AB THREE FOUR RIFLES
RESTORED THE PLACE TO THE
VETERINARIAN BY ALLOWING THEM
TO RECOMMEND CANNABIS AND
PROVIDING SAFE ACCESS TO PET
OWNERS IN A LICENSE REGULATED
MARKET. IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX
CALIFORNIA BECAME THE FIRST
STATE TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
HEALTH OF HUMAN PATIENTS BY
ALLOWING THEM ACCESS TO
CANNABIS. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
CALIFORNIA COULD BECOME THE
FIRST STATE ADVOCATE FOR THE
HEALTH OF ANIMAL PATIENTS BY
ALLOWING THEM ACCESS TO
CANNABIS. WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO MAKE CALIFORNIA THE LEADING
ADVOCATE FOR ANIMALS IN OUR
COUNTRY AND AROUND THE WORLD.
WITH YOUR SUPPORT EIGHTY THREE
FOUR WE CAN STAND ON THE RIGHT
SIDE OF HISTORY SPEAK UP FOR
THOSE WITHOUT A VOICE AND MAKE
THIS WORLD A BETTER PLACE FOR
ALL CREATURES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH TALKED ISSUE. NOT
TO MISS YOUR. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH WORK AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF BEST FRIENDS
ANIMAL SOCIETY AND OUR
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA MEMBERS
SUPPORTERS AND PARTNERS IN FULL
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
FOUR. FROM COMMITTED TO MAKING
SURE THAT EVERY ANIMAL AND
EVERY SHELTER IN AMERICA IS
DOCTORED INTO A FOREVER FAMILY
AND ONE OF THE WAYS TO ACHIEVE
THE POSITIVE OUTCOMES TO ENSURE
THAT PETS HAVE ACCESS TO ANY
AND ALL THERAPIES THAT MIGHT
INCREASE THEIR CHANCES OF
GETTING ADOPTED. HAVE TURNED UP
IN SHELTERS FOR A VARIETY OF
REASONS BUT IT'S OFTEN BECAUSE
THEY ARE FACING PHYSICAL
BEHAVIORAL OR PSYCHOLOGICAL
CHALLENGES THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
FULLY ADDRESSED AND SOMETIMES
THOSE CHALLENGES OCCUR BECAUSE
THEY LANDED IN THE SHELTER
NONFATAL ACTIVE CANNABIS THERE
BECAUSE ONE OF THE VALUABLE
TOOLS IN OUR TOOLBOX TO HELP
THOSE PETS GET WELL AND GET
ADOPTED INTO HOMES. AND WE HAVE
SEEN FIRST HAND THE THERAPEUTIC
BENEFITS OF NON PSYCHOACTIVE
CANNABIS FOR A VARIETY OF
AILMENTS AND ANIMALS INCLUDING
APPALACHIAN FEATURES OSTEO
ARTHRITIC PAIN AND ANXIETY
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR WILL
HELP ANIMAL RESCUERS AND ANIMAL
SHELTERS ACCESS TO NEW
THERAPEUTIC CANNABIS
APPROPRIATELY IN TWO IMPORTANT
WAYS IT WILL ALLOW
VETERINARIANS TO DISCUSS
THERAPEUTIC CANNABIS WITH PET
PARENTS AND ANIMAL RESCUE
WORKERS. WHO HAVE CUSTODY OF
ABANDONED ANIMALS WITHOUT FEAR
OF LEGAL REPERCUSSIONS AND IT
WILL BRING ANIMAL CANNABIS
PRODUCTS UNDER THE SAME
STRINGENT LICENSING TESTING AND
REGULATION GUIDELINES THAT
APPLY TO PRODUCTS INTENDED FOR
HUMAN USE. THESE CHANGES WILL
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR ANIMAL
RESCUE FACILITIES TO ACCESS
CANNABIS FOR ANIMALS THAT IS
APPROPRIATELY LABELED AND
ACCOMPANIED. WITH CLEAR
DIRECTIONS FOR YOU. AND THAT IT
WILL MEET THE HIGH NOT A
STANDARD BUILT INTO OF STATE
REGULATION TAX AND WILL. THAT
CAN AND PESAR AND AM RESCUER
UNPACKED. USE WE BELIEVE THAT
IS WHY MANY RIGHTS GROUPS AS
WELL AS CALIPH PENSION MEDICAL
SAYS. ARE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR
TWINPOWER MORE CALIFORNIANS TO
DO RIGHT BY THEIR PAST. AND FOR
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
SHELTER ANIMALS WHO NEED OUR
HELP EVERY YEAR THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WAS
WORKING GOING. TO PAUSE FOR ONE
MOMENT TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
LOW HERE. FOR A- YEAR ARAMBULA
BERMAN BLOOM CHEN. CHALE
CUNNINGHAM DALY FIVE YEARS
GIPSON GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN SALAS
TEAM. THE PHARMACIST I WISH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
STASHED A QUORUM THEN OPERATOR
WILL GO ON TO THE PUBLIC LINES
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT NAME AN AFFILIATION
ONLY. PLEASE IF YOU WISH TO DO
SO. YEAH FOR A PUBLIC COMMENT
IN FAVOR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
COULD YOU SHARE MEMBERS AND
FRANK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT EIGHTY
THREE FOUR THANKS SO MUCH. AND
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS CHRISTINA
DECARO REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA VETERINARY MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. AND WE
HAVE A NO FOR THEIR PUBLIC
COMMENTS IN FAVOR IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC CURRENTLY THE
CHAMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK AND
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. AND THREE
NINE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOMS
AT THIS TIME C. NINE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WHAT THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION WILL BEGIN WITH
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
THE COMMITTEE CHAMBERS-
ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS WITNESS BEGIN
OPPOSITION WILL LIMIT YOUR
PRIMARY WITNESS TESTIMONY TO
TWO MINUTES PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
WE'D LIKE TO THANK YOU THE
ASSEMBLY CARLA FOR HIS KEEPING
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE ON
THE FRONT BURNER AB THREE
EIGHTY FOUR ALLOWS
VETERINARIANS TO RECOMMEND
CANNABIS PRODUCTS FOR USE IN
ANIMAL AND LEGITIMIZES EXISTING
AND ALLOWS FOR NEW CANNABIS
PRODUCTS INTENDED FOR ANIMALS.
THAT SOUNDS GREAT. WHO WOULDN'T
WANT THAT WE ALL SUPPORT THAT.
BUT BEFORE THINGS DEVELOP THAT
WOULD LATER BE EXPLAINED AWAY
AS UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WE
ARE BOUND BY CONSCIENCE TO
POINT OUT WHAT AB THREE EIGHTY
FOUR DOES NOT DO. KHANNA'S
DISPENSARIES ARE BOTH ADULT USE
AND MEDICAL FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT ALLOW. MANY
JURISDICTIONS PROHIBIT ADULT
USE AND ARE ONLY MEDICAL FOR
EXAMPLE NAPA COUNTY IS MEDICAL
ONLY. CONSEQUENTLY THERE ARE
MORE MEDICAL DISPENSARIES THAN
ADULT USE IN CALIFORNIA. AB
THREE EIGHTY FOUR DOES NOT
CHANGE THE DEFINITION OF
DOCTOR'S RECOMMENDATION TO
INCLUDE VETERINARIANS IT JUST
PROHIBITS DISCIPLINARY ACTION
FROM THE VETERINARY MEDICAL.
THEREFORE THE VETERINARIAN'S
RECOMMENDATION WOULD BE
WORTHLESS IN NAPA COUNTY.
CHANGING THE DEFINITION AS WE
PROPOSE WOULD INCLUDE ANIMALS
AS PATIENTS UNDER MATH PERSON
AND RIGHTFULLY SO BECAUSE LET'S
FACE IT THERE'S NO SUCH THING
AS RECREATIONAL USE OF CANNABIS
FOR AN ANIMAL. THE GOVERNMENT
WARNING LABEL SAYS KEEP AWAY
FROM CHILDREN AND ANIMALS THEY
ARE DEFENSELESS HOWEVER WITH A
DOCTOR'S RECOMMENDATION
CANADA'S MAYBE INAPPROPRIATE
THERAPY. BY INCLUDING ANIMALS
AS PATIENTS IT ENTITLES THE
RESEARCHERS WITHIN THE UC
SYSTEM TO APPLY FOR A PORTION
OF THE FUNDS ALREADY ALLOCATED
BY PROP SIXTY FOUR. FOR
RESEARCH UC DAVIS AS A FULLY
LICENSED AND BA APPROVED
FACILITY FOR RESEARCH ON
ANIMALS. THURMOND STRUGGLING
FOR FUNDING FOR EVEN BASIC PRE
CLINICAL TRIALS FOR YEARS. THE
TAX REVENUES THAT THESE NEW
PRODUCTS GENERATE WOULD MORE
THAN- THAN OVERCOME ANY FEAR
DEFICIT OF A ON GOING RESEARCH.
THE VETERINARY MEDICAL BOARD AS
PROPOSED SPECIFIC LANGUAGE TO
BE INCLUDED IN VETERINARY
MEDICAL CANNABIS LEGISLATION
UNFORTUNATELY THERE NEXT BOARD
MEETING ISN'T UNTIL THE TWENTY
SECOND OF APRIL. I WOULD
EXPECTED MEMBER CARL WOULD BE
HEARING FROM THEM AFTER THE
BOARD MEETING. AB THREE EIGHTY
FOUR IS WRITTEN OPENS THE
FLOODGATES FOR BUT FOR BRAND
NEW ASPECT OF THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. AND ALSO LEAVES THE
DOOR OPEN FOR UNSCRUPULOUS. AND
OF. READERS AND GREED WE
PROPOSE THAT THE VETERINARY
CANNABIS PRODUCTS TO BE SOLD IN
MEDICAL RETAIL OUTLETS ONLY AND
ONLY WITH A VETERINARIAN'S
RECOMMENDATION. AS WE HAVE
STATED EARLIER THIS IS NOT
ABOUT ACCESS IT'S ABOUT SAFETY
AND PROTECTION AB THREE EIGHTY
FOUR SUGGEST THAT THE
REGULATORS WOULD HAVE SOMETHING
TO SAY ABOUT THE SAFETY AND
PRECAUTIONS. THE REGULATORS IN
HERE TO THE LETTER OF
LEGISLATION AND DID NOT
EMBELLISH THE NOTION THAT THE
REGULATORS WOULD INSERT SEEKING
PRECAUTIONS IS FALLING. IT
WOULD OPEN THE DOOR FOR
LITIGATION LET'S GET THIS RIGHT
THE FIRST TIME BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T PUT THE TOOTHPASTE BACK
IN THE TO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE- HAVE A POSITION OF OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING THE COMMITTEE
CHAMBERS WAS INTO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE BNP
COMMITTEE AND ASSEMBLY
MANPOWER. MY NAME IS DR GARY
RICHTER AND I REPRESENT THE
VETERINARY CANNABIS SOCIETY A
NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO THE SAFE
AND EFFECTIVE USE OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS FOR ANIMALS. AS THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE CONSIDERS
AB THREE EIGHTY FOUR. VCS
THANKS THE COMMITTEE AND
ASSEMBLY MANPOWER FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS WHAT HAS
THE POTENTIAL. TO BE
LEGISLATION THAT BENEFITS BOTH
PETS AND THE VETERINARY
PROFESSION. AS CANNABIS BECOMES
MORE BROADLY LEGALIZED
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY THIS
BILL MAY BE. MAY ACT AS A
TEMPLATE FOR OTHER STATE AND
FEDERAL LEGISLATORS AS THEY
CONSIDER HOW TO HANDLE CANNABIS
FOR ANIMALS. THE VCS SUPPORTS
THE SPIRIT OF AB THREE EIGHTY
FOUR IN THAT IT PROTECTS
VETERINARIANS FOR DISCIPLINARY
ACTION FROM THE VETERINARY
MEDICAL BOARD. WITH REGARD TO A
VETERINARIAN RECOMMENDED
CANNABIS FOR THEIR PATIENTS.
THIS APPROACH IS A CONTINUATION
OF AB TWO TWO ONE FIVE WHICH
BECAME LAW IN JANUARY OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ALLOWING
VETERINARIANS TO DISCUSS THE
USE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS WITH
THEIR CLIENTS. THE VCS
MAINTAINS VETERINARIANS NOT
MARKET FORCES SHOULD BE LEADING
THE KNOWLEDGE BASE AND
GUIDANCE. CONCERNING MEDICAL
CANNABIS USE FOR ANIMALS TO BE
CLEAR. THE ONLY GOAL OF THE
VETERINARY KIND OF A SOCIETY
WITH REGARDS TO EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY FOUR IS FOR THIS BILL TO
ENSURE PATIENT SAFETY. IN A VCS
IS VIEW THE CURRENT FORM OF
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR IS
LACKING NECESSARY SAFEGUARDS TO
PREVENT DANGEROUS TO ANIMALS.
WHOSE OWNERS SEEK OUT MEDICAL
CANNABIS FOR THEIR PET WITH OR
WITHOUT A VETERINARY
RECOMMENDATION. BECAUSE THE
BILL FAILS TO PROVIDE A
MECHANISM SUCH AS A WRITTEN
RECOMMENDATION FOR
VETERINARIANS TO BE THE ACTUAL
DECISION MAKERS AS TO THE
POTENCY AND STRUCTURE OF
MEDICAL CANNABIS SUPPLEMENTS TO
BE ADMINISTERED TO ANIMALS. THE
KEY QUESTION WHO DECIDES HOW
MUCH CANNABIS IS APPROPRIATE
MEDICINE IS NOT ADDRESSED IN
THE BILL AND LEAVES A GAP. THE
BILL ALSO APPEARS TO DUPLICATE
NOW CURSES TEN MILLIGRAM PER
SERVING. FOR ELIGIBLE CANNABIS
PRODUCTS INTO THE ANIMAL USE
ENVIRONMENT. TO BE CLEAR TEN
MILLIGRAMS OF THC FOR A SMALL
ANIMALS SUCH AS A SMALL DOG OR
A CAT COULD BE A LETHAL DOSE WE
HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
ADMINISTERING CANNABIS TO
ANIMALS MUCH LIKE WE WOULD TO A
SMALL CHILD THAT IS NON VERBAL
THESE ARE NONVERBAL PATIENTS
WHO CANNOT TELL US HOW THEY
FEEL. AND IN ORDER TO SEE IF WE
GIVE CANNABIS TO THESE PATIENTS
MEDICAL GUIDANCE IS. IS
NECESSARY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME HERE IN THE CHAMBERS. AND
NOW WE HAVE A JUST A NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING SUSAN TIVEN. LUCKILY IN
LEGALLY. MY POSITION IS THAT I
DO NOT SUPPORT AND LESS AMENDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. AND
AGAIN TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO TOOK TIME TO COME
IN. TO THE CHAMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ALSO IN
OUR COMMITTEE CHAMBERS WHICH IS
BEGIN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME.
WHEN I MOVE ON THE CONVERSATION
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ON THIS BILL SEEING NONE
THERE'S- A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION OF BOTH SIDES
BUT ASSEMBLY COVERED DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE. SORRY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR OF LONDON OPTION
PERCENT BOTH OF THOSE TODAY
WANT TO THANK YOUR STAFF FOR
THE WORK THEY PUT INTO THE
BILLS AS WELL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS EMMA KALRA AND A KUDOS
TO YOU AND YOUR TEAM- FOR
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE
OVER THE PAST YEARS I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE DEEPLY PASSIONATE ABOUT
IT. AND THAT YOU ALSO TAKE TO
HEART SOME OF THE COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS AS WE
CONTINUE. TO HELP AMPLIFY THIS
ISSUE. AS WE NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND. MOST BY. A MEMBER
HOLDEN SECOND BY ASSEMBLY.
WOMAN IRWIN. COOLEY SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB THREE
EIGHT FOUR KALRA TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA FLORA I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BERMAN
BERMAN I BLOOM. CHEN CHEN AYE
CHIU CUNNINGHAM DALY CHECK DALY.
FONG GIPSON GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA AYE MULLIN. SALAS KING
KING HI. TWELVE OH FIVE NEAR
KNOWS A NOTE TO A VICE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THE KALRA
COLLEAGUES WILL TURN TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY FOUR BY
SEVEN MEMBER KILEY. I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE CHAIR
AND- COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I'M
PRESENTED A BILL THAT I HOPE
CAN BE A POINT OF CONSENSUS.
THAT COBIT ERA SANCTIONS SHOULD
NOT BE EXTENDED. BEYOND THE CO
VIDEO. NOW WE ALL HAVE
DIFFERENT OPINIONS ON HOW THIS
LAST YEAR HAS BEEN MANAGED. I
MYSELF HAVE BEEN SOMEWHAT
CRITICAL YOU MIGHT SAY. OF THE
STATE'S APPROACH- TO LOCKDOWNS.
AND BUSINESS RESTRICTIONS AND
I'M SURE FOLKS HERE- AGREE OR
DISAGREE WITH ME TO VARYING.
DEGREES I WILL KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA'S HAD THE STRICTEST.
WALK DOWNS OF ANY STATE AND I
TEND TO BELIEVE MOST PEOPLE
DON'T TRULY BELIEVE THAT WE'VE
GOTTEN IT RIGHT. WELL THE OTHER
FORTY NINE STATES HAVE GOTTEN
IT WRONG. AND EVEN THE GOVERNOR
HAS SAID. QUOTE WE'RE ALL
GENIUSES IN HINDSIGHT. THE
PUTTING ALL THAT ASIDE. EVEN IF
YOU ARE OF THE MIND THAT THE
STATE HAS GOTTEN EVERYTHING
EXACTLY RIGHT. AND ANY
ESTABLISHMENT THAT WAS AT ANY
POINT OUT OF COMPLIANCE WAS IN
THE WRONG I STILL THINK THIS IS
A BILL WE SHOULD ALL SUPPORT.
TO ESTABLISH THE VERY IMPORTANT
PRINCIPLE.AGAIN THAT COVERT
ERA PUNISHMENTS SHOULD NOT BE
EXTENDED. BEYOND THE COVERED
AREA. THE QUESTION IS ADDS OUR
ECONOMY REOPENS IS OUR APPROACH
GOING TO BE PUNITIVE AND PETTY
OR FOR GIVING AND CONSTRUCTIVE.
WE FOCUS ON RETRIBUTION AND
RETALIATION OR ON RESTORATION
AND REVITALIZATION. MY BELIEF
IS THAT NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO
SETTLE SCORES IT IS TIME FOR A
MOVE EVERY OBSTACLE TO
RESTORING THE LIFE OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THE LIVELIHOODS
OF OUR PEOPLE THERE IS NO PLACE
FOR SPITE CERTAINLY NOT SPITE
BACKED. BY THE FORCE OF STATE
POWER. THIS BILL ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTY FOUR. INSURERS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
AND DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOL
BEVERAGE CONTROL. CANNOT
RESERVE REVOKE A LICENSE FOR
FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH COVERT
NINETEEN A MERCHANT'S YOURS.
UNLESS IT CAN BE PROVEN THAT A
LACK OF COMPLIANCE. CONTRIBUTED
TO THE SPREAD OF CODE NINETEEN.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THIS PROPOSAL. IN
THE CONTEXT OF. WHAT OUR SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY HAS GONE
THROUGH. SMALL BUSINESSES
COMPRISE ROUGHLY HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE THAT WAS
BEFORE THE ONSET OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND STATE DATA
RELEASED LAST AUGUST SURE THE
CLOSE TO HALF OF ALL CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES WERE AT RISK
OF SHUTTING DOWN BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC. MINORITY OWNED
ESTABLISHMENTS WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AND AFFECTED
THE SURVEY CONCLUDED WITH A
NUMBER OF BUSINESSES OWNED BY
AFRICAN AMERICANS DROPPED ABOUT
DROPPING BY 41% LATINO OWNED
BUSINESSES BY 32% IN ASIAN
OWNED BUSINESSES BY TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. ROUGHLY 36% OF
IMMIGRANT OWNED BUSINESSES WENT
UNDER AS ONE EXAMPLE TAKE THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY LAST AUGUST
ASIDE FROM THE THOUSANDS OF
RESTAURANTS THAT ALREADY GONE
OUT OF BUSINESS 30% SAID THEY
WOULD EITHER LOSE THE
RESTAURANTS PERMANENTLY WILL BE
REQUIRED TO DOWNSIZE.
OPERATIONS THIS WAS IN EFFECT
NOT JUST OF THE PANDEMIC
ITSELF. BUT OF COVERT NINETEEN
RESTRICTIONS THE WERE OFTEN
UNCLEAR. AND WE'RE CONSTANTLY
CHANGING. AS A RESULT MANY
BUSINESSES IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER AT ONE POINT OR
ANOTHER. WERE OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH THE STATE'S MANDATES.
SOMETIMES THIS IS BECAUSE THEY
WERE SIMPLY UNAWARE OF WHAT THE
MANDATES OR UNAWARE THAT THEY
WERE OUT OF COMPLIANCE. AT
OTHER TIMES THERE WAS A GOOD
FAITH DISAGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND THE
AUTHORITIES AS TO WHETHER THEY
WERE IN COMPLIANCE AND IN OTHER
OCCASIONS. YOU ESTABLISHMENTS
WERE FORCED. THAT HAVE FACED AN
IMPOSSIBLE CHOICE. WHETHER TO
OBEY MANDATES THAT DIDN'T EXIST
IN ANY OTHER STATE AND CLEARLY
WE'RE NOT DOING ANY GOOD. OR
WHETHER TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES. AND THEIR EMPLOYEES.
TO REJECT THIS BILL IS TO SAY
WE'RE GOING TO PROLONG
SUFFERING BEYOND THE LIFE OF
THE VIRUS. AND I JUST DON'T
THINK THAT'S RIGHT. AND I THINK
THERE ARE SEVERAL ADDITIONAL
REASONS WHY WE SHOULDN'T EXTEND
COBRA ERA PENALTIES. BE ON THE
COVERED AREA THE FIRST IS THAT
WOULD BE A DEPARTURE FROM OUR
CURRENT AND PAST PRACTICES.
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE CAMPUS WHEN
THIS STATE DECIDED TO REAL
LEGALIZE RECREATIONAL CANNABIS
WE DIDN'T SAY WELL FOR FOLKS
THAT IN THE PAST WERE CONVICTED
OF CANNABIS POSSESSION WE'RE
STILL GOING TO CONSIDER YOU A
CRIMINAL BECAUSE YOU NEWS
AGAINST THE LAW AT THAT TIME
AND YOU CHOSE TO USE IT ANYWAY.
NOW WHAT WE DID IS WE SAID NOW
WE'RE NO LONGER GOING TO
CONSIDER YOU CRIMINALS WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A CLEAN SLATE AND
LIKE THOSE CONVICTIONS CLEAN.
IN THE SAME VEIN NOW THAT
BUSINESSES ARE ALLOWED TO BE
OPEN OR GOING TO BE ALLOWED TO
BE OPEN. WE SHOULDN'T SAY WE'RE
STILL GOING TO PUNISH YOU. FOR
BEING OPEN IN THE PAST. WHEN
YOU WERE SUPPOSED TO BE. THE
SECOND ADDITIONAL REASON TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. IS THAT IF
WE PURSUE THE PATH OF A LICENSE
REVOCATION OF KEEPING
BUSINESSES CLOSED FOR PAST
PRACTICES IT WILL FAVOR LARGE
CORPORATIONS OVER THE SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. BIG
COMPANIES HAVE HAD BIG
COMPLIANCE DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE STATE BY STATE
GUIDANCE ON EXACTLY WHAT THEIR
FRANCHISES NEED TO DO- YOU KNOW
THEY'VE HAD- THEY'VE BEEN DOING
BY- I THRIVING STOCK MARKET AND
THEY HAVE. A LARGE MARGINS AND
RESOURCES. TO ABSORB THE COST
OF SHUTDOWNS THAT SIMPLY AREN'T
AVAILABLE TO SMALL BUSINESSES
AND IF THE GOVERNMENT NOW
ITSELF CAUSES ADDITIONAL SMALL
BUSINESSES TO CLOSE. IT IS ONLY
GONNA- ADVANTAGE THESE LARGE
COMPANIES EVEN MORE. THE THIRD
POINT I'D RAISE IS THAT THE
PROPOSAL THE PRINCIPLE THAT IS
IN THIS BILL IS IN THE INTEREST
OF PUBLIC HEALTH BECAUSE WHAT
IT SAYS. IS THAT OUR STATE
AGENCIES SHOULD FOCUS THEIR
RESOURCES ON THOSE
ESTABLISHMENTS THAT ARE
ACTUALLY CREATING A PROBLEM SO
THERE'S STILL THE OPPORTUNITY
IT REPLACES PURSUE SANCTIONS
BUT ONLY IF IT CAN BE
DEMONSTRATED THAT THERE'S BEEN
AN ADVERSE EFFECT ON PUBLIC
HEALTH. I THINK THAT ACTUALLY
WOULD GO A LOT FARTHER TOWARDS
CURBING TRANSMISSION OF THE
VIRUS THAT HAVING STATE
BUREAUCRATS GOING AROUND
SEARCHING FOR TECHNICAL
VIOLATIONS OR TARGETING
BUSINESSES THAT PERHAPS THE
MOST OUTSPOKEN- OR OFTENTIMES
YOU KNOW THESE ESTABLISHMENTS
OR- POLITICALLY DISFAVORED OR
JUST END UP BEING UNLUCKY. AND
THE FINAL POINT I'D RAISE IS
THAT THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
POSTAL FOR RESTORING TRUST
THERE'S BEEN A GREAT DEAL OF
DISTRUST BRED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- BY THE OFTEN EXISTENTIAL
RESTRICTIONS THAT WERE IMPOSED.
AND I THINK THAT THIS GESTURE
OF GOODWILL. WOULD REALLY GO A
LONG WAY. I WANT TO TAKE JUST A
MOMENT- IF YOU WILL TO ADDRESS.
A COUPLE ARGUMENTS THAT I'VE
HEARD RAISED AGAINST THIS
PROPOSAL. NOW THERE'S ALWAYS
THIS IDEA OF DETERRENCE THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE THESE PENALTIES
THERE IS A DETERRENT BUT THAT
SIMPLY DOESN'T APPLY TO THIS
SITUATION. YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
GONNA- WHAT WE'RE GONNA ASK
THESE COMPANIES THAT IS
BUSINESSES TO BEHAVE BETTER THE
NEXT TIME A ONCE IN A CENTURY
PANDEMIC COMES AROUND THIS IS
REALLY SOMETHING- THAT- YOU
KNOW IS. IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
IS GOING TO BE A RECURRING
PHENOMENON. AB SECOND THING A
POINT THAT'S ARGUMENTS AND
REYES IS THAT THERE IS- IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO ACTUALLY PROVE.
THAT BUSINESS WAS A CAUSE OF
TRANSMISSION BUT I THINK THAT
THAT VERY ARGUMENT IS A REASON
WHY WE SHOULD DOPT THIS BILL
ISN'T IS EVIDENCE ITSELF- THAT
THE STATE HAS NOT BEEN PURSUING
SANCTIONS IN A WAY THAT'S
GUIDED BY PUBLIC HEALTH BECAUSE
WE WERE REALLY CONCERNED. WITH
STOPPING BUSINESS ACTIVITY THAT
CONTRIBUTES TO TRANSMISSION THE
STATE HAS THE ABILITY TO
DEVELOP A CONTACT RAISING
SPECIAL TOOLS BY WHICH THAT
COULD BE DEMONSTRATED. BUT MAIN
ARGUMENT I HEARD AGAINST THIS
IDEA. IS THAT. IT'S SOMEHOW
REWARDING BAD BEHAVIOR IT'S
UNFAIR TO TREAT THE SAME-
BUSINESSES THAT DECIDED TO OBEY
THE ORDERS AND STAY CLOSED. AND
THOSE THAT DECIDED. TO OPEN. I
POINT OUT FIRST OF ALL THAT
EVEN IF YOU BELIEVE THAT.
THAT'S STILL NO REASON TO
PURSUE THE NUCLEAR OPTION OF AN
OF A LICENSE REVOCATION. I'D
CERTAINLY POINT OUT THAT THIS
IS AGAIN A DEPARTURE FROM LET'S
SAY THE WAY WE'VE TREATED
CANNABIS WHERE YOU MIGHT
SIMILARLY REYES THE POINT WELL
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT HAVE
WANTED TO USE CANNABIS WHEN IT
WAS ILLEGAL BUT THEY OBEY THE
LAW. AND SO NOW WE'RE TREATING
THEM THE SAME AS THE PEOPLE WHO
DID CHOOSE TO OBEY THE LAW. BY
THE SAME REASONING. THE SAME
REASONING WOULD APPLY HERE. THE
FINAL POINT I WANT TO RAISE IS
THAT THE WAY THINGS ARE BEING
DONE RIGHT NOW IF WE PROCEED
WITH THESE LICENSE REVOCATIONS
FOR TECHNICAL VIOLATIONS
THERE'S A MUCH GREATER- THERE'S
A MUCH MORE PERVERSE IN EQUITY.
WHICH IS TO SAY THAT BUSINESSES
THAT OPEN SAFELY ARE TREATED
THE SAME WAY AS BUSINESSES THAT
OPENED RECKLESSLY SO YOU COULD
HAVE HAD A BUSINESS THAT
DECIDED TO OPEN AND DID
EVERYTHING IT COULD TO MAKE
THINGS SAFE AND ELIMINATE ANY
REAL RISK OF TRANSMISSION YOU
KNOW THEY I. INSISTED ON MASKS
THEY PUT UP THOSE PLASTIC
DIVIDER THINGS- THEY DIDN'T
DEEP CLEANINGS EVEN THOUGH THE
CDC NOW SAYS THAT THAT. WAS
KIND OF POINTLESS MANY OF
ANOTHER BUSINESS THAT DECIDED
TO OPEN IT WAS COMPLETELY
RECKLESS AND PACKED PEOPLE INTO
TO TAKE ORDERS YET UNDER THE
WAY THINGS ARE BEING DONE NOW
THEY'RE TREATED EXACTLY THE
SAME DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE
MISTER KIND YES I'M CLOSING
RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND SO I THINK THAT IF WE'RE
GONNA TALK ABOUT EQUITABLE
FRIEDMAN. THEN THAT ACTUALLY
WEIGHS IN FAVOR OF THE CRITERIA
SET FORTH IN THIS BILL. BUT IF
THE STATE'S GOING TO PURSUE
PUNITIVE ACTION. THEN THERE
SHOULD AT LEAST NEED TO BE A
BURDEN OF PROOF ON THE PART. OF
THE STATE AGENCY TO SHOW THAT
THERE WAS HARM DONE. AND SO
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND- AS A
WITNESS TODAY I HAVE DAVID
BUTLER WITH UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR WOULD YOU
KINDLY OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
MISTER BUTLER MISS BUTLER UP TO
TWO MINUTES. FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT. A GOOD MORNING
CHAIR LOAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU THIS MORNING ON BEHALF
OF YOU CAN. UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK WHICH IS THE
COALITION OF LOCAL CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE ACROSS FOUR COUNTIES.
HERE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING OVER FIVE THOUSAND
MEMBER BUSINESSES. EACH YEAR WE
SURVEY MEMBER BUSINESSES
DETERMINE THEIR NEEDS AND
CONCERNS RELATIVE TO STATE
LEVEL ISSUES. AND
OVERWHELMINGLY THIS YEAR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS AND OPERATORS
INDICATED THEIR BUSINESS AT
BEEN. ADVERSELY IMPACTED BY
STATE AND COUNTY GOVERNMENT
DECISIONS IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. AND
NOW SEEK TO REOPEN THE ECONOMY
AND REACHED OUT WAS THEIR
BUSINESS OPERATIONS.
FORTUNATELY IN OUR CITIESAND
TOWNS ARE CHAMBERS HAVE STRONG
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND STAFF.
WHO REGULARLY BUT PARTICULARLY
DURING THE PANDEMIC. HAVE
WORKED WITH SMALL BUSINESSES TO
HELP THEM NAVIGATE CHANGING
MANDATE. DISTRIBUTE FEDERAL AND
STATE RELIEF. AND ALTER LOCAL
ORDINANCES TO ALLOW THEM TO
CONTINUE OPERATIONS WITHIN
SPECIFIC GUIDELINES. ARE
CHAMBER MEMBERS AND LEADERS
SEEK A SIMILAR REPORT LEVEL OF
PARTNERSHIP WITH YOU. THE STATE
LEGISLATURE IN THE DEPARTMENTS
AND AGENCIES THAT YOU OVERSEE.
IN THE PAST THE LEGISLATORS
MADE CHANGES TO STRUCTURE AND
PROCESS TO ASSIST SMALL
BUSINESSES MOST NOTABLY BY
ESTABLISHING SMALL BUSINESS OF
ADVOCATES WITHIN STATE
AGENCIES. AND ENACTING FIX IT
FIRST LEGISLATION ALLOWING
BUSINESS OWNERS TO AVOID
PURPOSE LAWSUITS. YOU CAN
CHAMBER STRONGLY SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTY FOUR WHICH
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY
MENTION SEEKS TO REMOVE THE
THREAT OF LICENSE REVOCATION TO
BUSINESS OWNERS AND OPERATORS
DURING THE CURRENT CODE
EMERGENCY. UNLESS SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS IS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
PARTICULAR BUSINESS. BY
APPROVING AB FIFTY FOUR YOU'LL
ONCE AGAIN POSITION THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AS A PARTNER WITH
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL BUSINESSES
HELPING THEM AVOID PUNITIVE AND
OFTEN ARBITRARY PUNISHMENT. AS
A RESULT OF THIS DECLARED
EMERGENCY THANKS FOR YOUR TIME
THIS MORNING WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I FELT MONEY BT
FOUR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR ANY ADDITIONAL.
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SEEN NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS OR IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOMS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. IN IS YOUR MIND
IF THEY'RE IN OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. GOOD MORNING TO REMEMBER
MY NAME IS MICHELLE GIVEN WITH
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE AT
THE STATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT YOUR HONOR STATE.
CALLING IN IN OPPOSITION K<c.cyan></c>
FIFTY FOUR. STATE AND LOCAL
HEALTH ORDERS ARE CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND PREVENTING THE SPREAD OF
DISEASE ESPECIALLY DURING A
PANDEMIC LIKE OF THE NINETEEN.
ENFORCEMENT OF THE BORDER THE
COURT GREATER COMPLIANCE. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
ENFORCEMENT BEGINS WITH
EDUCATION IT DOES NOT START
WITH CLOSURES AND ONLY ACTUALLY
THE PENALTIES INCLUDED AFTER
REPEATED INCIDENCES OF NON
COMPLIANCE. NON COMPLIANCE
COMES IN MANY FORMS AND CAN
RANGE FROM EXCEEDING THE
CAPACITY LIMIT. NEGLECTING
MAPPING REQUIREMENTS OR FAILURE
TO REPORT CRITICAL CASES AMONG
OTHERS. REQUIRING AGENCIES TO
PROVE A DIRECT CORRELATION FOR
EVERY INSTANCE THE SCENARIO OF
NONCOMPLIANCE AND TRANSMISSION
IS NOT FEASIBLE AND RISK
FURTHER SPREAD OF THE VIRUS.
GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF THE
ENDEMIC LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
RELIED ON THE ENFORCEMENT OF
THE STATE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL
WITH. A KEY PARTNER IN THAT
EFFORT EIGHTY FIFTY FOUR WOULD
PROHIBIT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND THE
DEPARTMENT A HOLIC BEVERAGE
CONTROL PROVOKING A LIFE. FOR
EVEN THE MOST EGREGIOUS PIZZA
THE NOT QUITE. BECAUSE THE
DIRECT RELATIONSHIP
TRANSMISSION WOULD NEED TO
FIRST BE TO BE ESTABLISHED AND
THAT COULD SIGNIFICANTLY DELAY
THINGS. DURING AN EMERGENCY
QUICK ACTION CAN SAVE LIVES AND
MUST NOT BE TENDER AND IT'S FOR
THESE REASONS THAT WE WERE
ACTUALLY MUCH. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES. WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE A NO ONE ELSE IN Q. AND
APPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENA ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING THE COMMITTEE
CHAMBERS NOR IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOMS. WHEN I MOVE ONTO A
CONVERSATION HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AT THIS TIME. SEEING NOTATIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY DO WISH TO CLOSE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
VICE CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A I THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- THIS DOES NOT ENJOY A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION THIS THEIR-
FIRST RECOMMENDATION IS A NO
VOTE AT THIS TIME- AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S BEEN A-
MOTION BY THE VICE CHAIR AND
THE SECOND BY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
DOWN TWENTY SIX I PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB FIFTY FOUR KILEY
DO PASSED A GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION LOW NO. LOW NOW
FLORA. FLORA HI ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA ONE BERMAN BERMAN NO
BLOW. CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY HI FONG.
FONG HI. GIPSON GRAYSON GRAYSON
NO HOLDEN. IRWIN. MCCARTY
MEDINA. MEDINA NOW MULLIN.
SALAS TAKING TAKING THEM. FOUR
EYES FIVE NOTES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS CALL WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
CLOSE WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR
TO ADDITIONAL AUTHORS. WE'RE
CURRENTLY NOT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AND SO SEEING THAT
DO AUTHORS ARE NOT CURRENTLY
HERE IN THE CHAMBERS. WELL THEN
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE. WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR BY MYSELF
ALL GOING TO TURN OVER THE
GAVEL TO OUR VICE CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- PRESENTING AB.
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR VICE CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR WHICH AS YOU KNOW
OF THIS COMMITTEE HAS AREAS OF
JURISDICTION OVER THE FISHERIES
BUREAU. BUT I MUST CONFESS THAT
THIS ISSUE WAS PUT BACK ONTO
OUR RADAR WHEN THE FREE BRITNEY
DOCUMENTARY WAS RELEASED IT
SHOULD LIGHT ON THE MANY
PROBLEMS WITH THE
CONSERVATORSHIP IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE DOCUMENTARY IS
A TRAGIC STORY OF A TALENTED
YOUNG WOMAN WHO REACHED THE
HIGHEST PEAKS OF FAME. AND WAS
LUCKY. AND THEN BECAME ISOLATED
HARASSING ALSO CITED A POINT OF
BREAKING DOWN. BUT THIS BILL
ISN'T JUST ABOUT BRITNEY SPEARS
SOME WOULD SAY TE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS A CIRCUS. AFTER DOING
OUR OWN RESEARCH ON THE
CALIFORNIA'S CONSERVATORSHIP
LAWS WE FOUND THAT A HUGE
EFFORT TO REFORM THE SYSTEM IN
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX DID NOT
TAKE EFFECT. DUE TO THE TOXIC.
ECONOMIC RECESSION THAT STARTED
IN TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT. IN
ADDITION THE LOSS DID NOTHING
TO HELP PEOPLE AVOID
CONSERVATIVE SHIPS. CREATE
RESOURCES FOR FAMILIES ARE
PROVIDE FUNDING TO MAKE
EXISTING SYSTEMS WORK BETTER.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN NINETY
FOUR CREATES A MUCH NEEDED
OVERSIGHT IN THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM REQUIRES THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM TO COORDINATE WITH THE
LICENSING ENTITY OF PRODUCERS.
AND GIVES US MORE PROTECTIONS
FOR PEOPLE UNDER
CONSERVATORSHIP. IT SHOULD BE
CRIMINAL TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
PEOPLE PLACED IN
CONSERVATORSHIP MOST OF WHOM
ARE SENIORS AND VULNERABLE TO
ABUSE. LET'S NOT MAKE THIS AN
OOPS MOMENT WE NEED TO HELP
THOSE WHO ARE IN NEED TO
PROTECT THEMSELVES. IT'S OUR
PREROGATIVE AS MEMBERS OF THE
BUSINESS PASSIONS COMMITTEE TO
GIVE THE FUTURES BUREAU THE
TOOL TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT. PLEASE HELP US MAKE
THE CURRENT LAWS STRONGER THAN
YESTERDAY. BY VOTING I ON THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. THIS WE HAVE A SECOND.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I DO NOT THINK WE HAVE
ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES SO WILL
OPEN UP HER TESTIMONY IN THE
GALLERY IN THE CHAMBER. SEEN
NONE IN THE CHAMBER ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN NINETY
FOUR IN THE WITNESS TESTIMONY
ROOM. C. N. NINE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT FOR A BI IN ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR ON THE PHONE LINE
WAS MODERATE YOU CAN OPEN PHONE
LINES. AND THEN IF THEY ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
TWENTY ONE TO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BY CHURCH MEMBERS THIS
IS JERRY DEATH MAN ABOUT HALF
OF THE PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA PEACE
FACT TO NOTE THAT- WE ARE
WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW. AND THE HIS OFFICE ON A
NUMBER OF PROVISIONS THAT ARE
ON THIS BILL AS IT MOVES
FORWARD. AND WE APPRECIATE THE
ENGAGEMENT AS THE ISSUE
ADDRESSES OF THE- CONCERNS THAT
ARE OUT THERE THAT HAS
EXPLAINED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALTHOUGH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE SIXTY THREE SIX THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
RICHARD CALLAGHAN WITH PETER
I'M SPEAKING IN FAVOR OF AB
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR TODAY WITH
RESERVATIONS BUT THE AUTHORS
OFFICE BEEN WORKING FORWARD SO
I. URGENT TO MOVE ON TO
JUDICIARY MY BIG CONCERN IS
WORK SPANNING THE PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARIES BUREAU AND THAT
YOUR- IS COMPLETELY BROKEN AND
EXPANDING A BROKEN SYSTEM IS
THE WRONG MOVE IT NEEDS TO BE
REFORMED BEFORE EXPANDED. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE HAVE A NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS IN
FAVOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
BRING IT BACK FOR OPPOSITION ON
AB ELEVEN NINETY FOUR. ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE CHAMBER FOR
ELEVEN NINETY FOUR. C. NINE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE WITNESS
TESTIMONY ROOMS FOR ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR. SCENE NINE MISTER
RODERICK YOU OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR OPPOSITION AB. ELEVEN
NINETY FOUR. AND IF THERE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO WE
HAVE A NO PUBLIC COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ROOM. ANY COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
C. NINE I'M GONNA TAKE A FEW
JUST A MOMENT TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS IN THE MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND IT'S AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT TAKE SOMEBODY
LIKE BRITNEY. TO BRING A VERY
SERIOUS ISSUE FORWARD BUT I AM
PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY AND I'M PROUD THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY FOR FIRST TIME SINCE
I'VE BEEN HERE YOU KNOW
ACTUALLY FREE BRITNEY AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
THAT OUTSIDE OF SOMEBODY FAMOUS
THIS ACTUALLY HAS A VERY BIG
DEAL TO A LOT OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS ON A DAILY BASIS
SO THANK YOU BRING THIS FORWARD
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
SUPPORTING THIS BILL THANK YOU
WELCOME TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF VICE YOUR FLOOR AS
YOU KNOW THIS COMMITTEE HAS HAD
JURISDICTION OVER NUMBER THE
SENSE OF INCLUDING THAT OF
FIDUCIARIES BUREAU THIS
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO INDEED AS I STATED EARLIER
MAKERS LAWS STRONGER THAN
YESTERDAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
A ELEVEN NINE FOUR LOW DO
PASSED TO JUDICIARY LOW HIGH.
LOW HIGH FLOOR. FLORA HI
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HEIGHT
BERMAN. BERMAN HI BLOOM. CHEN
CHEN HI CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DALY.
FONG. FONG HI GIPSON GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN IRWIN HI
MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA HI
MULLIN MULLIN I SALAS SALAS
NINETEEN TANG HAI. FOURTEEN ICE
ZERO KNOWS THE VERY MUCH OF THE
FULL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR REAL
ISSUE MEMBERS AT ALL THANK YOU.
BECAUSE WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR
ADDITIONAL TWO MEMBERS 2% WHO
ARE NOT MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE SO WE'LL JUST GO BACK
INTO. A FILE ORDER AS WE LACKED
A QUORUM AT THE TIME SO WILL BE
JUST THE BEGINNING AND FILE
ORDER SO THAT'S ABOUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR SIXTY EIGHT AND DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES- WE NEED A MOTION
AND A SECOND. SECOND MOVE BY
NUMBER GRAYSON THE SECOND BYE
BYE SURE FLOOR COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FOUR SIX EIGHT FRIEDMAN DO
YOU PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA. FLORA
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA BAKER BERMAN.
BERMAN HI BLOOM CHEN CHEN HI TO
YOU. CUNNINGHAM DALLI DALLI HI
FONG FONG HI GIPSON GIPSON HI
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN IRWIN AYE
MCCARTY. MEDINA ENOUGH TIME
MULLIN MULLIN I SALAS SALAS I.
EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN ISER KNOWS.
FIFTEEN IS THE BILL IS OUT AND
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO THIS IS ASSEMBLY
BILL. TWO NINETY THREE BY SOME
A MEMBER KALRA THIS ALSO ENJOYS
TO DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE. NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND. MOVED BY
MEMBER GIPSON SAID BY MEMBER
TING THREE SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB TWO NINETY
THREE KALRA TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA. FLORA ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BERMAN. BERMAN HI
BLOOM CHEN CHEN HI Q.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY HI FONG
FONG HI GIPSON GIPSON GRAYSON
GRAYSON HI HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN. IRWIN HI MCCARTY MEDINA
ENOUGH TIME MULLIN. MULLIN I
SALAS SALAS EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
HI. FIFTEEN AYE ZERO KNOWS.
FIFTEEN IS WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THE
BILL IS OUT. FILE UNDER NUMBER
THREE. THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE EIGHTY FOUR BY SOMEONE
MEMBER KALRA DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN A MOTION
AND A SECOND- SO COMMUTER TAPE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB THREE
FOUR KALRA DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM. QIU
CUNNINGHAM. GIPSON GIPSON I.
THIRTY MULLIN. MULLIN HI SALAS
SALAS HI. FIFTY NINE ZERO KNOWS
FIFTEEN I THE BILL IS OUT ONE
WE'VE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS AND I SEE
THAT WE- SOMEONE IS THERE ANY
IS HERE IN THE CHAMBERS- SEVEN
ZERO HAS. TWO BILLS. WELL GO IN
FILE ORDER FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX. WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL-
THREE NINETY TWO. IN THIS FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE NINETY TWO IS A MEMBER
AND IS THERE IN THIS DOES ENJOY
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS IN PREVIOUS YEARS
AFTER LEGISLATION THAT WOULD
MODERNIZE AND- MAKE MORE
EFFICIENT. HOWSAM SOURCE PLASMA
PROTEIN IS- DERIVED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND AB
THREE NINETY TWO AS AMENDED
SIMPLY CLARIFIES HOW STANDARD
OPERATING PROCEDURES ARE
DEVELOPED BY PLASMA DONATION
CENTERS. IN CALIFORNIA. AND TO
MAKE THIS PROGRAM A PERMANENT
PROGRAM WITH THAT I- CONCLUDE
MY STATEMENTS HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR AYE
RECOMMENDATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND SOME OF THEM AREN'T IS
THERE AND THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
AND SECOND. OF OPERATOR WOULD
YOU KINDLY OPEN THE LINES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AS PRIMARY
WITNESSES. IF THEY WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO.
HI THIS BILL SPEAR- WHAT THE
PARTNER PROTEIN THERAPEUTICS
ASSOCIATION. WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
THIS COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT OF
OUR PILOT PROJECT IN PART
LEGISLATIVE SESSION AND WE
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR FAVORABLE
BUT TODAY. I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COUNTY DELGADO
ON BEHALF OF QUICKBOOKS PLEASED
TO BE IN SUPPORT. AND A
MULTILINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING THIS IS
JAMIE FACT THEN ON BEHALF OF
THE IMMUNE DEFICIENCY
FOUNDATION REPRESENTING OVER
THIRTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
THE PRIMARY NEAR DEFICIENCIES
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. SEVEN NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SEE NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
THE CHAMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OR IN THE COMMITTEE
CHAMBERS WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP LINES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SORRY PUBLIC COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE A
LINE COMMUNITY ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. WE WILL GO TO LINE
SIXTY EIGHT SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES ARE YOU MISTER CHAIR
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. EVENT NO
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE
NO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING THE CHAMBERS OR
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS SPEAK
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND ASSEMBLY MEMBER MISSOURI
DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB THREE NINETY TWO
IN THIS AREA DO YOU PASS LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA. FLORA I
ARAMBULA. BERMAN BERMAN HI
BLOOM CHEN CHEN HI QIU.
CUNNINGHAM DALLI DALLI HI FONG
FONG HI GIPSON- GIPSON HI
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN IRWIN AYE
MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA AYE
MULLIN- WHEN I SALAS SALAS HI
TEAM. CHIANG HI. FIFTY NINE
ZERO NO FIFTEEN IS WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS SOMEONE IS HEARING FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB. TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES I WILL KEEP THE
PRESENTATION BRIEF BUT IF YOU
DON'T MIND I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE MERITS OF THIS BILL
ARE CRITICAL- AB TWELVE SEVENTY
EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE PHYSICIANS
AND SURGEONS WHO RECEIVE
PAYMENTS FROM. A DRUG OR DEVICE
COMPANY TO DISCLOSE THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS AND WRITING TO
EACH PATIENT PRIOR TO
TREATMENT. THE DISCLOSURE WOULD
REQUIRE A LINK. TO THE ALREADY
EXISTING FEDERAL OPEN PAYMENTS
WEBSITE AND A PATIENT
SIGNATURE. OPEN PAYMENTS IS A
IS THE EASY TO USE FEDERAL
WEBSITE. WHICH LISTS FINANCIAL
EXCHANGES BETWEEN DRUG AND
DEVICE MANUFACTURERS AND HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS GOING BACK TO.
TWENTY FOURTEEN. ALL YOU HAVE
TO DO IS TYPE IN YOUR DOCTOR'S
NAME AND YOU CAN SEE IT. IF YOU
CAN YOU CAN SEE IF THEY'VE
RECEIVED MONEY AND FOR HOW MUCH
AND FOR WHAT DURATION INCLUDING
EVEN FREE LUNCHES. IT'S A VERY
SIMPLE PROGRAM IT'S EXTREMELY
EFFECTIVE AND IT'S
TRANSPARENCY. I THINK PROVIDES
THE CREDIBILITY NECESSARY. FOR
ALL DOCTORS TO CONTINUE DOING
WHAT THEY'RE DOING. WHILE
ACCEPTING THESE PAYMENTS DO NOT
NECESSARILY TRANSLATE INTO A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST PHYSICIANS
FAILING TO AFFIRMATIVELY
DISCLOSE POTENTIALLY RELEVANT
INFORMATION CAN PUT THAT
RELATIONSHIP TO RISK. ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS A WENDY CONNECT
WHO UNDERWENT UNDERWENT BREAST
RECONSTRUCTION IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN FOLLOWING A DOUBLE
MASTECTOMY. SUFFERED GREATLY
SHE NEEDED TO HAVE SIX MORE
SURGERIES TO UNDO WHAT HAD
HAPPENED IN THE FIRST SURGERY.
IT WAS FOUND OUT THAT SHE HAD
THE BRCA GENE WHICH MADE HER
VULNERABLE FOR BREAST CANCER SO
SHE WENT IN TO GET A DOUBLE
MASTECTOMY. THE DOCTOR THE
SURGEON THAT WAS RECOMMENDED TO
HER CAME EXTREMELY- RECOMMEND
HIGHLY RECOMMENDED BUT WHAT HE
DID NOT DISCLOSE TO HER IS THAT
HE AS USING A DEVICE. A
PRODUCT THAT WE HAD NOT BEEN
FDA APPROVED. IT'S FINE THAT IT
WAS AN FDA APPROVED HE COULD
STILL USE IT BUT HE NEEDED TO
LET HER KNOW THAT HE IS GOING
TO BE UTILIZING- A PROCEDURE
AND THE PRODUCT. THAT HAS NOT
BEEN FDA APPROVED AND THAT IT
COULD CAUSE SEVERE CHALLENGES.
HE DID NOT. WENT AHEAD AND
UTILIZE THAT ON HER. SHE
SUFFERED SO GREATLY THAT SHE
HAD HAD SHE HAD TO HAVE SIX
MORE SURGERIES IN ORDER TO
UNDO. WHAT HAD BEEN DONE THIS
WAS SOMETHING THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN RESOLVED WITH WITH ONE
SURGERY. SHE BROUGHT THIS ISSUE
UP TO ME SEVERAL YEARS AGO
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON IT- OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST
LITERALLY TWO AND A HALF YEARS.
IN ORDER TO BRING IT. TO THIS
POINT TODAY- WITH ME. I AM
JOINED BY DR CHARLES ROSEN
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF THE
ASSOCIATION FOR MEDICAL ETHICS
OF WHO IS ALSO THE INDIVIDUAL
WHO AUTHORED THE OPEN RECORDS
FEDERAL. RECCA OPEN RECORDS
PROGRAM AS WELL AS MY
CONSTITUENTS WENDY CONNECT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THERE ARE TWO I WILL
LIMIT TESTIMONY FOR UP TO TWO
MINUTES PER INDIVIDUAL PLEASE
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WELCOME
HELLO. OKAY HI MY NAME TWENTY
CONNECT AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK TODAY NO I THINK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN THERE AND GET THE
HELL MY BACKGROUND THOUGHT GET
THAT PART. BUT I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT A SIMPLE DISCLOSURE OF
MY DOCTOR CONFLICT OF INTEREST
WOULD HAVE BEEN POWERED MY
HUSBAND WHO IS A PHYSICIAN I
NEED TO ASK THE RIGHT
QUESTIONS. HAVING KNOWN ABOUT
THESE FINANCIAL CONFLICT I
WOULD NEVER HAVE CONSENTED TO
THE SURGERY AND SUBSEQUENTLY
COULD HAVE AVOIDED. SEVERE
COMPLICATIONS REQUIRING. THE
SEVERAL UP. AND THE CAN PAIN IN
THE- THAT EXIST. I ALWAYS
THOUGHT I WAS AN INFORMED
CONSUMER. BUT MY SITUATION
MAKES IT ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
WITHOUT KNOWING ABOUT YOUR
DOCTORS POTENTIAL CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST IT IS IMPOSSIBLE FOR
ANY PATIENT. HAVE FULLY
INFORMED CONSENT. AS OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN A VERY
POINTED OUT THE TYPE CAN ALSO
BE A POSITIVE BUT IT'S THE
PATIENTS RIGHT NOW DISCLOSURE
OF FINANCIAL HIGH IS LEGALLY
REQUIRED WHEN A DOCTOR SENT YOU
TO A FACILITY THEY HAVE A
FINANCIALINTEREST THE PATIENT
MUST SIGN A DOCUMENT BUT
FINANCIAL DISCLOSURE IS NOT
REQUIRED WHEN THEY PRESCRIBE A
DRUG FOR YOU DOING JACK OR
DEVICE TO IMPLANT INSIDE YEAH.
THAT'S THE THING PREPOSTEROUS
THINK ABOUT OPIOIDS THE DRUG
COMPANIES INCENTIVIZED DOCTORS
TO PRESCRIBE THE TICKETING
KILLED THOUSANDS OF PATIENTS
AND THE HIGH COST OF
PRESCRIBING BRAND NAME DRUGS
OVER. THAT HOSTAGE IN THERE IT
DOES. FACED WITH THE- A DOCTOR
MAKE TWICE. IT'S BEEN A ONLY
RIGHT FOR A CASE TO FACT THE
SAME TYPE. OF TRANSPARENCY FROM
A DOCTOR THAT'S REQUIRED WHEN
YOU'RE REALLY CHAIR OR YOUR
FINANCIAL ADVISOR. I KNOW THIS
COMMITTEE DEEPLY ABOUT PATIENT
PROTECTION PASSING AB ONE TWO
SEVEN EIGHT WILL DO JUST THAT
IT WILL EMPOWER PATIENTS WITH
THE ESSENTIAL INFORMATION THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT NOW LIFE DEPENDS
ON. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PRIMARY
WITNESS PLEASE. MY NAME IS
CHARLES ROSEN I'M A PROFESSOR
OF ORTHOPEDIC SURGERY AT THE
UCLA SCHOOL OF MEDICINE AND A
PRACTICING PHYSICIAN FOR THIRTY
YEARS AS WELL AS PRESIDENT OF
THE ASSOCIATION FOR MEDICAL
ETHICS. IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS I WAS SURPRISED TO
SEE THAT A CERTAIN MEDICAL
DEVICE PASSED THE FDA IN
AMERICORPS STUDYING WAS TAKEN
OFF THE MARKET TWO YEARS LATER
AFTER MANY PEOPLE WERE INJURED
IN MY OPINION. I LATER FOUND
OUT THAT MANY OF THE AUTHORS OF
THE STUDY AND SUBSEQUENT
RESEARCH ENDORSING THE PRODUCT
HAD BEST FINANCIAL INTEREST IN
THE SUCCESS WHEN THIS WAS DONE
ON THE PATIENTS AND DOCTORS. IN
AFRICA LEGISLATIVE FINANCIAL
TRANSPARENCY ENDED UP SPEAKING
WITH SENATORS CALL AND GRASSLEY
RESPONDED TO THIS NEED BY
PROBING THE- LEGISLATION CALLED
THE POSITION PAYMENT SUNSHINE
ACT WHICH- MISTER NAZARIAN
REQUIRED. I WAS ASKED BY THE
SENATORS TO TESTIFY BEFORE
CONGRESS FOR IT WHICH I DID THE
ACT. PASSED IN REQUIRES ALL
MEDICAL. THE COMPANIES TO RIP
TO THE FROM AT THE- TO THERE
MONEY OR THE LACK AND HOW MUCH.
INDUSTRY RESISTED REVEALING
FINANCIAL DETAILS OF SUCH
PAYMENTS THE POSITIONS IN
RESEARCH OR PRACTICE BECAUSE IT
BRINGS OUT FOR ALL TO SEE THE
POTENTIAL FINANCIAL BIAS IN
RESEARCH OR PATIENT CARE MAKE
THAT. THIS OFTEN MAKES DOCTORS
IMPATIENT PRESIDENT THAT
PARTICULAR DEVICE OR DRUG TOLD
MORE INDEPENDENT RESEARCH IS
DONE. INDUSTRY DOES NOT WANT
ANY DELAY OF THIS MAY HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVE EFFECT ON PROFITS FOR
THAT PRODUCT. THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THIS AB TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT
ONLY MAKE PATIENTS AWARE IN
WRITING OF THIS DATABASE THEY
CAN ACCESS REGARD ANY COMPANY
THE DOCTOR HAS THE LIST OF
HAVING A FINANCIAL POWER.
NOTHING MORE THE DOCTOR DOES
NOT HAVE TO GIVE ORAL
NOTIFICATION OR AMOUNTS OF
COMPANY PAYMENTS INVOLVED.
THERE'S NO INCREASE IN DR
PAPERWORK OR TIME JUST ANOTHER
SIGNATURE PAGE PER PATIENT.
PATIENTS HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
IF THE DOCTOR HAS AN INDUSTRY
TI<c.cyan> HAVE ACCESS THAT IF THEY</c>
WANT AND AS IMPORTANTLY. THIS
IS PART OF LEGALLY MANDATED.
INFORMED CONSENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT
CONCLUDES THE- OPPORTUNITY FOR
PRIMARY WITNESSES TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY. WHEN I MOVE ON TO
THE LINE'S OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SIGNIFY THEIR SUPPORT WITH
NAME AND AFFILIATION. JUST AS A
MEMBER OF REMINDER FOR THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS IF YOU ARE IN
FAVOR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND THAT WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY
SEVEN SIX SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING YES PLAIN COLORED
WITH HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. AND NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE FIFTY EIGHT FIVE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SURE NUMBERS RACKET MARKETS
REPRESENTING THE SPONSORS OF
THE BILL THE GENERAL PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AN EXCELLENT LINE
FIFTY TWO FIVE TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE GREER LEVIN CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CONSUMER WATCHDOG
TO EXPRESS THEIR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR A BI TWELVE NINETY EIGHT
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT. IN FAVOR PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR SEE NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS OR THE COMMITTEE
ROOMS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY FOR WHEN THIS
IS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR.
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AND
LIMITING YOUR COMMENTS TO NO
MORE THAN TWO MINUTES EACH
THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN A POSITION AT THIS TIME.
AND ONE MOMENT FOR OUR FIRST
COMMENT. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
SIXTY FIVE SIX FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. SORRY NOT PRIMARY
OPPOSITION BUT IT'S ENOUGH TO
GET YOU KNOW WHAT KEEP YOU
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS GOOD LUCK MAN DID WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR TOPIC. THANK YOU. WE
HAVE A NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. HERE NO
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC COMMENT
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HEARING THE
COMMITTEE CHAMBERS WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THE
TIME. C. INDEED IT MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHICH SPEAK PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO STATE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO
DO SO WELCOME. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS EMILY HUGHES ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION WE SIMPLY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR ON BEING AND
HIS STAFF. CLEAR THAT UP AFTER
BEING SO MINIMAL THUS FAR AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
WORK ON FURTHER AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. SENIOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHICH TO
BEGIN OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS OR IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM. NOW CAN THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE- THERE'S
BEEN IN MOTION AND A SECOND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KNOWS THEIR AND
YOU WISH TO CLOSE. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO SIMPLY STATE THAT. MY
CONSTITUENT WHEN AND FOR WHAT
WAS RELATIVELY A SIMPLE
RECONSTRUCTIVE WORK. HAD SHE
KNOWN THAT HER DOCTOR HAD
RECEIVED FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
PRODUCT THAT HE USED- I THINK
SHE WOULD HAVE DONE MORE
RESEARCH AND MAYBE GONE TO
ANOTHER SURGEON. IT'S JUST THE
BASIC RIGHT FOR US TO KNOW TO
BE ARMED WITH THE INFORMATION
IN ORDER TO MAKE MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS FOR OURSELVES. WITH
THAT I HUMBLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
SOMEONE IS THERE AND JUST
DIFFICULT FOR CATION YOU ARE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. YES YES YES ONE
THANK YOU. AS AMENDED THERE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PASSION UNITED SPOKE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE TO AND YOU. GAVE A
DIFFERENT GUARDED THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS TOO AND- WE
ARE EQUALLY COMMITTED TO
HELPING ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. A
CONTINUE TO CONTINUALLY MOVES
FORWARD. I WITH THAT COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT
NAZARIAN TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORIDA. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA
AYE BERMAN BERMAN HI BLOOM.
CHEN CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DALY.
FONG GIPSON OUR. GREAT GIPSON
HI GRAYSON ALL GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN. IRWIN IRWIN HI MCCARTY.
MEDINA INA HI MULLIN. MULLIN I
SALAS SALAS EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
HI. TEN I. ZERO NOTICE TO NICE
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THIS YEAR IN
COLLEGE WHERE AT ARE A LAST
BILL PRESENTATION THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE. THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD SOME
OF WHAT THIS DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS AT CHEMISTRY CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PERCENT. I'LL BE
BRIEF- BUT I DO WANT TO GET A
COUPLE THINGS OUT THERE. AB
FIVE TWENTY SIX IS A RATHER
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL THAT
ACCOMPLISHES TWO THINGS FIRST
IT CODIFIES CURRENT
AUTHORIZATION GRANTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
ALLOWS DENTISTS AND
PODIATRISTS. TO INITIATE AND MR
VACCINES APPROVED BY THE FDA
FOR COVERT NINETEEN. UNDER THIS
BILL THE ADDITION OF VACCINES
TO THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE FOR
DENTISTS AND PODIATRISTS IS
CONDITIONED ON THE SAME
TRAINING RECKON RECORDKEEPING
REQUIREMENTS INCLUDED. IN THE
DCA WAIVERS THAT FARM THE
PHARMACISTS ARE CURRENT
CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO COMPLETE
IN ORDER TO ADMINISTER
VACCINES. IN TWENTY TWENTY I
AUTHORED AB SEVENTEEN TEN A
BILL THAT AUTHORIZED
PHARMACISTS TO AND KIND OF THE
INITIATE AND ADMINISTER
INFLUENZA VACCINES APPROVED FOR
AUTHORIZED BY THE B. THE FDA.
THIS BILL MAHER IS THAT BILL BY
ALLOWING APPROPRIATELY TRAINED
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS TO
ADMINISTER VACCINES INTO EXPAND
ACCESS TO COPE WITH NINETEEN
VACCINATIONS. THE SECOND PART
OF THE BILL ALIGNS CALIFORNIA
LABORATORY REGISTRATION STATUTE
WITH FEDERAL LAW SO THE DENTIST
CAN OBTAIN. THE APPROPRIATE
STATE REGISTRATION ALONGSIDE
THEIR FEDERAL LICENSURE- TO IN
ORDER TO CONDUCT SIMPLE
RELIABLE WEIGHT TEST THAT. ARE
WITHIN THEIR SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
I COULD GO ON BUT I THINK I CAN
THAT'S IN THE INTEREST OF TIME
I WOULD JUST SAY- HERE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE TWENTY SIX.
AND RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE A STAR IN THE
GROUP. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION THANK MISTER
CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVALS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR WOULD. NOW MOVE ON TO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT-
EITHER ON THE LINES OR IN THE
CHAMBERS RIGHT NOW AND WE CAN-
WITH- MISTER GROUP. FROM DAY
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTS MIGHT
TO NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING KAREN MEMBERS
DYNAMIC GREW ON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
ON BEHALF TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
NUMBERS. AS THAT DOCTOR WOULD
HAVE SAID JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING
I WILL JUSTSIMPLY THAT READ
REITERATE THAT DENTISTS HAVE.
WHOLEHEARTEDLY JUMPED IN TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE COMMUNITY
VACCINATION EFFORTS THEY STAND
READY POISED. AS WE MOVED INTO
THE NEXT STEPS OF THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH EFFORT  AM HERE. FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE
ANY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHICH IS
SIGNIFIED THEIR SUPPORT. AND
ONCE AGAIN FLT THERE ARE
PUBLIC COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
APOLOGIZE THIS IS RYAN SPENCER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PARTY AFTER
THE MEDICAL ASSOCIATION WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INCLUDING THE PODIATRIST IN THE
BILL AND WE ARE VERY MUCH IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY THREE
FIVE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN CHRIS
MY NAME IS FRED NO WHERE
REPRESENT ESOS ATION UP DENTAL
SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE A NO FOR THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEN
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS OR
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOMS AT THIS
TIME WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC TESTIMONY FROM MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. OPERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. MISTER PUBLIC COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO. YEAH BUT NO PUBLIC CAPITA
NOT POSITION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SCENE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC HEARING THE
CHAMBERS OR THE COMMITTEE ROOMS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. IN THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WE DO NEED A SECOND.
SECOND BY A SUMMER FONG. DR
WOULD YOU WISH TO CLOSE. I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
WOULD. PLEASE CHECK AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB FIVE TO SIX
WOULD DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA. FLORA I ARAMBULA.
MERIMBULA HYPE BERMAN. BERMAN
HI BLOOM. CHAN CHAN HI CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE DALLI
DALLI IPHONE FONG HI GIPSON.
YEAH BUT GRAYSON OKAY GRAYSON
AYE HOLDEN THE- IRWIN. IRWIN
AYE MCCARTY WAS RECOVERED ABOUT
MEDINA MEDINA NINE MULLIN.
MULLIN HI SALAS I SALAS HI
EIGHTEEN. EIGHTEEN HI. HAND HIM
FOR THE DISEASE'S DATA FORTY
NINE ZERO NOTES FOURTEEN ICE
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THE RUMORS
TALKED WITH COLLEAGUES WILL
JUST THEN GO BACK. TO THE VIEW
THAT CONCLUDES OUR BILL
PRESENTATIONS AND WE'LL JUST GO
BACK TO SOME OF THE ITEMS THAT
WE STILL NEED TO GET OUT.
BECAUSE WE MOVED TO CONSENT.
WOULD I CONSENT CALENDAR IF
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY DOCTOR
RAMBLER SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS. MISTER TERRY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON CONSENT.
AB FOUR EIGHT FOUR MEDINA AB
FOUR EIGHT SIX QUIRK DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS AB FIVE TO
SEVEN WOULD DO PASS LOW HI LOW
HI FLORA FLORA I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA ALRIGHT BERMAN. BERMAN
HEIGHT BLOOM CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI DALLI
DALLI HI FONG FONG ALL RIGHT
GIPSON. GRAYSON MASON I HOLDEN
IRWIN IRWIN HI MCCARTY MEDINA
MEDINA HI MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
SALAS SALAS I EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
HI. FORTY NINE ZERO KNOWS
FOURTEEN ICE OKAY WE'LL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. HIGHS WILL GO BACK TO
INFO ORDER THEN FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL. FIFTY FOUR.
SHARES RECOGNITION NO. AB FIFTY
FOUR KILEY DO PASSED A
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION BLOOM.
QIU CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM HI.
GIPSON HOLDEN. MCCARTY MULLIN.
MULLIN NO SALAS. TAKING. THE.
YEAH THIS IS KIND OF. YEAH.
CHOOSE YOU KNOW. CHIU NOW. FIVE
FIVE SEVEN KNOWS FIVE SEVEN AS
WE LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. CALL BEFORE
YOU LEAVE LET ME GET THAT OF A
JUMP TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
AND AS WE DO NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND THIS IS AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THIS BEEN IN MOTION BY MISTER
GIPSON. A SECOND BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TEAM. TWENTY SECOND
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ARAMBULA DO YOU
PASS AS AMENDED CHIU JUDICIARY
LOW HIGH LOW HIGH FLOOR. ARAM
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I BLOOM. CHEN QIU. CHIU
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOW
DALY JALINGO FONG. FONG NO
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN. IRWIN
MCCARTY MEDINA IN AYE MULLIN
MULLIN AYE SALAS SALAS EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN HI FLORIDA FLORIDA.
TEN ICE FOR KNOWS. CHEN ICE THE
BILL IS OUT AND WILL BE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. THOSE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ELEVEN THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
THIRTY. HOW CAN SOMEWHERE GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE ROLE ONE LAST
TIME. AS I SEE ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES HERE SO WE'LL GO IN
A FILE ITEM ORDERED THEM NUMBER
ONE. ASSEMBLY BILL. FOUR SIXTY.
AB FOUR FIFTY EIGHT FRIEDMAN
BLOOM. QIU. CHIU HI CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM HI MCCARTY. SEVENTY
NINE ZERO NO SEVENTEEN IS THE
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWO ASSEMBLY BILL TWO NINETY
THREE BY SOMEONE KALRA AB TWO
NINE THREE COVER TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM. QIU CHIU
I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
MCCARTY. SEVENTY NINE ZERO
KNOWS SEVENTEEN IS THE BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
THREE EIGHTY FOUR KALRA. AB
THREE EIGHT FOUR KALRA TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
BLOOM. QIU CHIEW HI. CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM HI. SEVENTY NINE
ZERO NO SEVENTEEN I THE BILL
WITHOUT. FILE ITEM FOR FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR THIS IS AB
FIFTY FOUR CHAIRS RECOGNITION
NO. AB FIFTY FOUR KILEY DO
PASSED TO GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION BLOOM. GIPSON.
HOLDEN. THE PARTY. SALAS. FIVE
I SEVEN KNOWS FIVE EYES. SEVEN
KNOWS THAT BILL FAILS. FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB THREE NINETY
TWO BY SEVEN MURDERS AREA. AB
THREE NINETY ON THE SYRIAN DO
PASS ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA ALRIGHT
BLOOM. QIU QIU HI CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM HI MCCARTY. MCCARTY
HI. EIGHTEEN AYE ZERONOS
EIGHTEEN EYES THAT BILL IS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT BY SOME
THE NUMBER NECESSARY. AB TWELVE
SEVENTY EIGHT NAZARIAN DO
PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BLOOM. Q. CHU HI
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI MCCARTY
MCCARTY HI. TWELVE FIVE ZERO
KNOWS TWELVE IS THE. ELEVEN I
ZERO YES. ELEVEN ICE ON AB
TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT LET'S HEAR
IT THE BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM.
NUMBER NINE AB FIVE TWENTY SIX
BY SOME REMEMBER WHAT. JUST ONE
MOMENT AND CHAIR. THANK YOU. I
APOLOGIZE THAT WOULD THIRTEEN
EYES ON AB TWELVE SEVENTY EIGHT
ZERO KNOWS A CORRECTION
THIRTEEN EYES ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN AB TWELVE SEVEN
EIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT. AND
THEN- WE'RE MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB FIVE TWENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD. AB
FIVE TWENTY SIX WHAT DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BLOW. QIU QIU
HI GIPSON. GIPSON HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI MCCARTY MCCARTY HI.
EIGHTY NINE ZERO KNOWS EIGHTEEN
IS THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY BY DR RAMYA. AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ARAMBULA TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO JUDICIARY BLOW. CHEN.
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI IRWIN IRWIN HI
MCCARTY MCCARTY HI. THIRTEEN
NINE ZERO KNOWS THIRTEEN I IS
THE BILL AS OUT. AND FINALLY
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR LOW. I
APOLOGIZE ON THAT ONE LATIMES
CHAIR AB FOURTEEN THIRTY HAS
THIRTEEN NICE FOR KNOWS. J. AB
FORTY THIRTY THE BILL IS OUT.
AND THEN FINALLY FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FOUR LOW. THIRTEEN
NINETY FOUR LOW DO YOU PASSED
TO JUDICIARY QIU. CHIU HI HELLO
CUNNINGHAM. HELLO CUNNINGHAM HI.
MCCARTY MCCARTY HI. SEVENTY
NINE ZERO KNOWS SEVENTEEN IS
YOUR KNOWS BECAUSE WILL BE
THERE WILL OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
THREE MINUTES FOR I DON'T. AND
I AND AN EVENT CONSENT. CONSENT
ITEMS FOUR EIGHT FOUR MEDINA AB
FOUR EIGHT SEVEN QUIRKY PASTOR
PERFUSION AB FIVE TO SEVEN
WOULD DO PASS CHU. CHU HI.
BLOOM GIPSON. HOLDEN HOLDEN HI
MCCARTY MCCARTY HI SEVENTEEN
FIVE ZERO KNOWS OKAY CONSENTS
OUT. IF YOU GET. AND.
I
REMEMBER THE FIRST COUPLE OF.
AB FOUR SIX EIGHT FRIEDMAN TO
PESTER PREPARATIONS MCCARTY
MCCARTY HI. SEVENTEEN AYE AYES
ZERO KNOWS. AB THREE EIGHT FOUR
KALRA D. PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MCCARTY. MCCARTY
HI. EIGHTY NINE ZERO KNOWS. AND
AB FIFTY FOUR KILEY DO PASSED A
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
MCCARTY. MCCARTY HI. SIX I
SEVEN KNOWS.
WE ARE TURNED.